[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raconte loire mais petite beauté qui
nous rejoignent pour le prime spéciale
c'est que de labour alors je vais tout
vous raconter les chéris on devait faire
un prime spécial paranormal et puis on
s'est dit que c'était un petit peu
anxiogène 1 comme sujet voilà surtout en
ce moment et on n'a pas eu envie
vraiment d'annuler se prennent donc on
s'est dit on va faire un prime c'est que
de l'amour avec tous des images d'amour
bien sûr drôle l'amour vu par nos
chroniqueurs l'amour vu par camille
combal
on aura un gros rendez-vous à 21h20 j'ai
vraiment vous demandez à tous si vous
pouvez vraiment d'être là pour un grand
rassemblement qu'on va faire il y aura
grégoire et kids unitaid qui vont nous
nous chanter toi + moi on va tous se
prendre par la main on va tous se faire
des bisous ça va être un très très très
très beaux moments et on aimerait que
chez vous vous fassiez de même voilà
parce qu'on voulait être là avec vous
une semaine après les drames qui sont
survenus bien sûr sur paris on voulait
que vous ne sentiez parmi vous et qu'on
soit avec vous un petit peu chez vous
pour vous accompagner ce soir et je vous
le dis on fait ça pour vous mais on fait
aussi ça pour nous parce qu'on avait
besoin de vous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
alors on aura comme les salles de
personnalités qui nous diront que c'est
que de l'amour aussi ce soir y aura même
des messages pour vous gilles verdez
vous verrez voilà deux personnes qui ont
souhaité vous dire qu'il vous aimez
malgré tout ce qui s'est passé vous
verrez et puis bien sûr on aura les
chroniqueurs qui ont préparé plein de
choses hein vous verrez il ya erika
moulet vous allez voir je pense dans du
dance dance acrobatique
il ya mathieu delormeau on a une petite
surprise pour lui ça va arriver très
vite si vous avez à être premier combat
qu'on vend père et puis qu'est ce que
vous montrez bayer tout congrès
[Applaudissements]
premier dans la vie c'est la première
fois de ma vie
de quoi que je mets un noeud papillon
vous avez l'air d'un magicien ya thierry
moreau carrément au jeu vous dire mais
il ya un truc qui va pas et ce soir je
vais tout faire pour que vous ne soyez
plus jamais comme avant
vous verrez bien entendu y aura isabelle
morini bosc qui nous a fait du french
cancan
il ya une aura malagré qui vous a prévu
un un tour de magie vous dévoiler petit
et bien ce sera encore plus petit
oui c'est possible un bateau de colle en
fait à une stricte dans l'instant et à
la bnf à la déjà une angoisse depuis la
médaille la bêta il est là elle a commis
l'erreur de dire qu'elle savait faire
quelque chose
j'ai vérifié auprès de son entourage et
cette chose est vraie on verra on va
tester ça dans un instant pour le moment
on va démarrer ce prime avec camille
combal et n'oubliez pas le rendez-vous
vraiment soyez avec nous à 21h20 très
très très précise et c'est important
aussi c'est un appel des sceaux et ce
racisme aussi pour qu'on soit tous
ensemble main dans la main et on sera
avec vous bien sûr ce soir alors mon ami
juste avant conscrites alors de touche
pas à mon poste
on est en train de faire un nouveau jeu
qui ne m'arrange pas voilà le jeu de la
franchise va rappeler alors le jeune
artiste pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
alors le principe est simple cyril je
posais une question tous les
chroniqueurs avait un casque ils n'ont
pas entendu voix et cyril selon la
question celui auquel y pense il doit
lui amener la pièce on tire à pile ou
face pile on donne la question fasse ça
reste en secret à tout jamais ouais vous
avez choisi jean michel maire alors on
va rappeler la question
alors j'ai choisi
[Rires]
c'est que de l'amour sous ceux de
mamours alors donc j'ai choisi jean
michel bergue oui donc il a il a fait
pile ou face vous êtes tombé sur piste
dans kill bill
ça veut dire de la franchise ça veut
dire que c'est la question que je vous
ai posé vous allez devoir l'a donné à
jean michel mr a expliqué pourquoi c'est
lui que vous avez choisi c'est le
principe face vous n'auriez jamais rien
su et jean michel c'est vous qui donnez
la question oui bon et vous arrivez vous
faites vos rêves les plus fous se
retrouve mal s'efface alors à ses pieds
j'ai posé une question toute simple la
syrie parce que voilà on passe beaucoup
de temps ensemble en loge en dehors et
j'ai posé une question à cyril toute
simple j'ai dit en les croisant avec la
proximité en loge des requêtes et
l'ambiance j'ai demandé quel est selon
cyril celui parmi tous les chroniqueurs
ici présents qui pue le plus de la
gueule
[Rires]
je vous ai choisis on sait pas ce que
vous bouffer le dire mais il est un peu
tôt
on va ça démarrait
ce proche de marc barr mais jean michel
vous adosser est ce que vous sentez tout
ce beau mais vous parfois voilà on sent
qu'elle y est garé votre bouche est
habitée je la prends donc faire
attention vous la prenez juste
donnez moi la pièce est une autre
question qui a mis en jeu nous opposer
une autre à bord ils devaient du total
et une petite tournée à grand coup de
barre après la méga ce canal est séparé
des casques comme étaient tous les cas
ce cas les remettez les gars qui ont été
avec leca s'attend guère si léché
attention à l'est la question il
faudrait e le kg à la pièce c'est vous
qui allez vais arriver bien alors
attention
bertossa mauroy est là fort n'arrête pas
de chanter tout à l'heure allez on y va
aller shihri alors là c'est jane
kaczmarek et où vous l'entendez le
public aussi cyril way entre nous ouais
quand vous êtes en dehors de tp mp oui
quand vous reprenez votre vie normale
votre téléphone sonne on vous appelle
tous un petit peu parfois je change qui
nous plaît on se calme la non mais alors
oui entre de cyril quand on vous appelle
est-ce qu'il y en a un dans l'équipe
quand vous voyez son numéro s'afficher
sur votre téléphone vous décrochez pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attendit l'électrification sympa oued
qui sont sympas il faut tirer à pile ou
face
mathieu ne sera jamais qualité la
question alors c'est valérie vili c'est
pile on va savoir
alors on va devoir lui dire que je
voulais ce faire vous la question que
j'ai posée à cyril c'est simple c'est en
dehors de tvnp on l'appelle tous un peu
parfois et je vais demander si parmi
nous tous quand il voit le nom
s'afficher sur son téléphone y en a à
qui
bah il décroche pas forcément
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
répondez jamais bah ouais ouais mais
c'est souvent aux toilettes merci mais
est ce que vous voulez en faire une
petite dernière j'en ai eu à l'élan
allez c'est bon
comment voulez-vous à est d'accord et
une petite dernière après il ya deux là
dedans on doit y aller allez une petite
dernière parce que ça je pense que ça va
revenir comme séquence dans touche pas à
mon poste c'est un spray une spéciale
c'est que de l'amour et c'est vrai que
ça débat repart de la bri c'est vraiment
une bonne ambiance
allez on y va s'il vous plaît pardon je
me remets du choc
allez on y va attention si lille ouais
on sait que toute l'équipe prépare
l'émission bien sûr s'intéresse aux
émissions qui regardent celle dont vous
parlez mais est ce que vous trouvez
sincèrement que dans l'équipe il y en a
parmi tous ceux là mais qui bossent
moins que les autres qui peut être
gagnant un peu trop par rapport au
travail qu'il effectue dans la journée
mais naïve
le ton était surcoté attention sa part à
gauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du tout
[Applaudissements]
alors quand même il ya des trucs sympa
alors pile ou face
si je pars c'est face et dont on ne
saura jamais merci
[Applaudissements]
oui
jouera jouera pas je suis peut-être le
seul en france mais chez les replays
chez moi mais je vous conseille pas
rester comme ça rester dans l'ignorance
ça vous connaît prime autour de l'amour
ce soir autour des bisous donc je me
suis demandé comment est-ce que cyril
exprime son amour dans la vie on aura
aussi un bêtisier de camille et baba il
y aura le retour du black swan deux des
huit matthieu delormeau des spéciales
dance du love
ok vous allez voir ça mais les poteaux
autour de la table s'y connaissent aussi
en amour parfois ils aiment tellement
qu'ils ont je vais vous dire ils font la
boulette dans les loges on a la preuve
en a retrouvé à willer enfant viendra
quelques uns tout au long de la
chronique
alors ceux qui l'ont rejoint a bien sûr
des huttes qui me connaissent peut-être
pas l'émission qui viennent spécialement
pour ce prime time alors les enfants de
stars c'est que c'est toi qui aime ces
deux personnes qui se rencontrent qui
font la moue rire on retrouve leurs
enfants sur la télévision et là on va
commencer avec erreur et s'il avait pris
la photo on voit le plus mais dans les
copains vous avez des photos on voit
pavot dont vous avez vous savez que la
dernière fois il ya une étude qui est
sorti non mais jure que c'est vrai nom
mais je vous jure thierry gérard les
dents d'enora c'est 70% de sa taille
mais là on pouvait dessiner des trucs à
lille alors que webber regarder on a
retrouvé leurs enfants c'était un
charmant jeune homme
d'ailleurs regardez on l'a retrouvé ah
j'adore j'adore en star est le même dans
la restauration de baisse de
fréquentation et la maman qui m'a envoyé
un message très beau de lambeaux trop
beau d'armes au mercer regard des jeunes
a pas c'est en direct regarder trop beau
delormeau et ouais il rentre dans la
famille haas russie là elle veut je peux
venir déjeuner dimanche vous allez
déjeuner mais sans moi qui tue la gueule
aussi en celui qui pue de la gueule
aussi le mien c'était en moi la bêta
mais alassane ouattara trouvez vous ce
que c'est que de l'amour ce soir excuse
moi toi tu prend des initiatives comme
ça srx et notre chauffeur le salue ses
pizzas il a envie qui sortent à sa maman
bébé je te fais un bisou c'est que de la
mosquée un travail formidable on eric on
aime fort
[Applaudissements]
à la mécanique
c'est quoi l'amour pour l'exprimer ça
passe souvent par des chansons d'amour
les sharks où deux chiennes charles
aznavour et autres keen v et sa solide
l'a bien compris c'est vrai qu'ils
devaient qu'il est avec nous il n'a pas
pu mais il a failli venir devraient nous
chanter dans un monde meilleur
bien sûr et notre pavarotti du petit
écran a toujours aimé interpréter des
chansons d'amour c'est son truc il aime
ça on a même retrouvé des archives bon
avec cyril je vous rassure 1 il rajoute
toujours sa petite patte à lui dans les
chansons d'amour
c'est le propre des génies on peut pas
lutter ça c'est quoi ça je cherchais jeu
de jean teulé ce temps pour que tu pas
tant
mais quand je regarde c'est jean luc
lemoine jean luc lemoine qui vous a
donné ces images sera là pour les
questions quatre tirs tout à l'heure
apparemment je pense que ce prime c'est
que de l'amour mais pour moi ça va être
que la galère un peu plus gros on a tous
et la corde ou l'agrément qualité
ouais merci merci c'est bon j'ai une
petite version johnny aussi cyril quel
point les chansons p norge contre c'est
dommage de passer à faire trembler les
murs de jéricho
je vais péter personne n'a jamais été je
vais péter plus fort que mes rêves sont
imaginé un artiste universel
[Applaudissements]
en fait on aime un spectacle avec
jean-luc le mois des roches en j'ai tous
les maux et mes par péter dans les
chansons voilà ça le comble depuis cyril
a bossé savoie il atteint la perfection
une voix cristalline du sud de tunis
c'est de la pub plutôt la pub qu'on
destine à paris lé 6 mois sera proche de
10 buts ce qui lui permet même d'être
invité par de grands artistes je vous le
dis comme patrick bruel pour chanter
avec lui c'était cet été quoi vous avez
ça mais ça c'est une horreur non non
c'est bien chanter ah non je lui ai fait
flinguer la chanson non non c'est pas
mal on à l'entrée patrick est tellement
impressionné sont donné rendez vous
place des grands hommes de jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait non
c'est pas si mal en même temps que ses
classes quand tu chantes avec patauge
mais regardez ce que ça donne imaginez
on enlève patrick on enlève le
guitariste on enlève la barbe on met
votre moi c'est plus la meinau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est arrivé
[Musique]
elle a mais l'évêque sais c'est que de
l'amour le thème c'est grâce aux bourdes
oui sinon c'est la thèse c'est berne qui
ravagent la corse moi même c'est ça et
la raison alors zaïre trouvé ça et le
costume on en parle away est le costume
d'homme je travaillais dans un
restaurant chinois voici c'est bien
d'avoir changé un peu faim mais des
toits il ya d'autres trucs tout ce truc
encore je vous rassure thalassa pas sa
chronique alors vervotte anciennement
mais là on se dit tous il a tous les
talents en suisse du showbiz animateur
chanteur et homme de scène aussi hein
parce que lancé sur orbite par ses
talents de chanteur
le petit rossignol a décidé de se lancer
solo sur scène sans jean-luc ses
papilles nissan et en 2004 non il est
sur scène isla j'y parle de tout il
révélé même ses fantasmes à l'épreuve on
sait pas sur qui fantasment cyril celle
qui occupe et toutes ses pensées à
l'époque regarder hamsik hostile parce
que moment j'avais pensé comme ça à nick
est utile parce qu'elles tuent joe nick
et inutilement tu vois comme ça j'avais
une playlist nous on a [ __ ] ultime
option 1
annick et petits mots jaillissent alors
qui est-ce qui l'amitié cette femme est
ce que c'est ophélie winter naomi
campbell les spice girls peut être un
allié petit mot j'aï valérie bene
ce qui me chagrine c'est le utilement
moi mais bon basso va parce que vous
êtes vous êtes une star c'est ça ma rue
pourriez me faire monter
c'est sûr qu'elle vous aurez fait monter
le son à voir la suite du stage parce
qu'on peut pas parler d'amour sans
parler de valérie syrie lisador c'est
vraiment faire un concert quand ils vous
aiment votre syrie l'un près face à ces
deux puits qui vous connaît 1 h 40 vous
connaître en 2004 c'était moins évident
j'ai arrêté le sketch on va voir la
suite du sketch je vous laisse la
découvrir
regardez pas et venez l'essayer valérie
muller l'animatrice la petite brune avec
une moustache
non franchement vous n'avez jamais
remarqué sur la vie de ta tâche des
croisés dans la rue la semaine dernière
avec une guitare à la main je t'ai
francis cabrel l'évêché lumbroso là j'en
ai marre qu'on me dis moi tu ressembles
à belley je vous laisse regarder
le pire c'est en 2004 oui moi on se
connaissait pour de vrai oui oui bah oui
non moi donc je manque alors vous avez
un tatouage tribal à la place de la
barbe l'arrachement des trucs
géométriques la ccha d'or franchement
camille comment tu te barres ah oui
c'est vrai j'ai pas vous en étiez dans
l' enquête non c'est horrible c'est ça
les mecs
d'ailleurs son régime j'écoute de dix
copains qu'il en soit les catskill de
coûts d'un milliard de la débrancher les
mandats mais vous à nourrir la danse que
des voix il ya quelqu'un qui m'apaise
depuis tout à l'heure à j continua
chronique dans ses yeux d'engueuler oui
mais oui c'est qui c'est qui c'est qui
pas qui sait encore ce pathos là il me
dit vous n'avez pas de moustache
[Rires]
maintenu la peine vous décrochez quand
c'est moi quoi qu'est ce qu'il a la
chute de chambre quand on est personne
dispose est telle qu'un tout petit peu
connus de roche pour personne inquiète
là bas même pour moi marquer dès les
prochains même chose vous vous croyez
qu'on fait avec annie c'est la première
fois que je déteste autant votre
chronique non mais césar vous allez voir
aujourd'hui cyril et valent ils sont
inséparables
cet ensemble à la télé à la radio et on
vous comprend franchement valery en caux
pente vous lâchez jamais cyril parce que
il est toujours d'un grand soutien avec
nous tous est avec vous valérie comme
dans ce passage radio que vous êtes à la
radio chaque jour il vous oblige à
chanter du lara fabian devant lara
fabian c'est pas gênant et une fois que
vous vous lancez noter que série dans
absolument mais rien à [ __ ] ils
voulaient seul dans un désert de
solitude on tuerait dit au pasteur il
aille se faire pendre et mon nom n'est
plus à vendre a laissé cette nuit car
que serait ma vie sans lui c'est bon
c'est bon
alors que valérie a toujours confiance
en vous et cyril enfin presque
regardez bien le geste de valérie tu
oublies les caméras quand cyril annonce
à une auditrice qui paye assez frais
voyez hf chose que je ne fais pas mon
ami c'est moi je vais vous envoyer en
séjour pour deux de trois jours et deux
nuits et vous dites
anne fauconnier la secrétaire générale
d'europe 1 que c'est chez moi qui vais
offrir ça à camille parce que je peux
pas elle vous avez vous avez vous est ce
que c'est vrai ou pas c'est vrai c'est
vrai quand vous dites que c'est pour
vous vous le faites vraiment et elle
vous envoie vraiment d'ailleurs la
facture bravo et il n'est jamais une
moustache de trèbes est si gentil très
recherchés c'est tombé sur vous ça
aurait pu tomber sur wii mais vous aimez
tellement que finalement apparemment
vous avez consommé tous les deux chuté
pas au courant on a retrouvé votre
enfant de star les amis rapidement cyril
et valérie oh non c'est un jeune garçon
qui était interviewé dans un jt dans un
jardin et sa petite amie
on l'a retrouvé sur la télé regard des
membres pourrait bien battre le record
sont super bien
[Applaudissements]
c
c'est la personne si vous ne voyez sur
des beats ta prime spéciale c'est que de
l'amour on est en direct on tenait
vraiment à être avec vous ce soir avec
tout ce qui s'est passé
bien sûr cette semaine tous les
événements tragiques on voulait être
avec vous une semaine après et voilà
vous sentir qu'on est là qu'on s'a bus
qu'on rigole un peu parce que ça fait du
bien et c'est vrai que merci d'ailleurs
au chroniqueur d'être là et camille je
vous dis même si je m'en prends plein la
gueule
j'aime beaucoup cette chronique j'espère
quelques années encore pour longtemps et
encore beaucoup de chose et encore plein
de choses là de leur modem ce qui arrive
notamment
mais je vous rassure vous n'êtes pas la
seule 1 valérie acquis ce bel éphèbe à
piétiner le coeur avec ses santiane
crado moi aussi j'ai souffert sur les
mémoires et l'habitude de montrer nos
problèmes de couple vous le savez devant
les caméras mes camarades autour de la
table sont habitués en revanche à avoir
leur tête on sent que les invités sont
beaucoup moins habitués à vendre nos
petites chamailleries
je me suis rendu compte en regardant
l'émission du canton ce schéma et quand
je veux faire la chronique
les invités se demande absolument ce qui
se passe à chaque fois on a pris
quelques heures comme ça au hasard ils
sont au bout du rouleau regarder ça je
ne touche plus tu vas faire parce que je
derrière je vais divorcer en vérité je
te pète les bras
tous les deux se tuent personne de voile
avait contourné lois de ce pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis voir ce que j'allais mettre le
lendemain à la plage ivoire avec
monsieur sur son époque tous et bravo à
mal un jeu se stabilise la gueule hockey
enfin la phase aller mostacchi moustachu
[Applaudissements]
schilb il médias ça va tu viens pas
longer en détente sur une merguez quand
même on va quoi on casse on reprend on
t'a se reprend au casse en reprend mais
à un moment on va casser et on pourra
plus mais le goal pour se rabibocher
ce sera un cas sable je veux dire
peut-être pas j'ai dit nick kounis même
qui ne sent pas tout ça c'était sympa
c'est bon qu'est-ce que j'ai tout allait
bien entre cyril et moi jusqu'à
l'incident le drame douloureux épisode
de la main l'idée géniale de cyril
refaire la scène de la belle et le
clochard avec une banane il s'est rendu
compte bien trop tard qu'on aurait du
mal à assumer sa après un sensible et
fan de bananes s'abstenir de prendre sa
place on doit faire quoi
[Musique]
oh
ça va très loin
ça va trop loin trop loin
cette panade
[Musique]
dans moins de trois minutes maintenant
vraiment soyez tous sur d8 avec nous on
va faire un bon moment puisque yahia
grégoire qui va venir avec titre united
on fera tous toi + moi main dans la main
avec le public avec vous un chez vous et
j'aimerais que vous nous prenez des
photos de cet instant chez vous et que
vous le nous les métiers sur twitter et
de rappel vous rappelle le hashtag c'est
que de labour a bien sûr ce soir mon cas
biya d'autres choses qui arrivent oui
elle a même fini par ce film et cyril et
moi parce qu'on sait mettant comme les
cards à xian la conférence de kani et
baba et qu'on a dû arrêter pour des
raisons évidentes de pedro dans mon
salaire on verra on verra comment ça je
suis dispo vas-tu te calmos rabot ce
boulot là réussie du béton touche c'est
quoi c'est normal ça fait mal aux doigts
et vas-y bon pourtant on se marrait
beaucoup pendant les tournages la
complicité était encore là on a déjà
quelques petites images de bêtisiers
devons regarder c'est moi ça pique
porc-épic excuse moi oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
qu'est tanus mairie ça suffit tu sors de
la salle de bain ça fait deux heures que
j'attends la balle hors jeu c'est ce
qu'ont dit les voyages forment la
jeunesse
c'est par là
il ya un nouvel an voire deux stars
alors qu'abby juste on va annoncer
l'entente de star ce sera qui est qui ce
sera quelqu'un de l'équipe auquel je
voulais penser aussi bien sûr qui est
pas là autour de la table qui est juste
à côté c'est moctar et dany boon qui ont
eu un enfant ensemble sur la télévision
on verra leur enfant dans un instant
mais je vous demande et je vais demander
au tout public de se lever
je demandais à tous les chroniqueurs de
se lever bien sûr se prendre par la main
on va avoir ce moment et vous twittez
chez vous vos photos vous prenez tous
par la main parce que à 21h20 c'est un
appel aussi café et sos racisme
vous sortez vous écouter de la musique
ou bien vous nous regardez vous nous
tenez par vous tenez par la main et ya
grégoire qui est avec qui tu dit elle
qui va nous faire toi + moi les chéris
[Applaudissements]
qui sait
et tous ceux qui sont au sol venez et
entrez dans la tente installée
et venez laisser-faire l'insouciance à 2
amis je sais qu'on n'est pas tout et
possible tout est
abl on peut
s'enfuir
bien plus au keno
parti
un plus grand que la grèce
plus noir
qu est ce qui le voit suis plus seule
plus tous ceux qui sont sommes là
venez
est entré dans
notre jour de chance avec
la force et le courage neuf fois
rapport à son que des miroirs
malheur pour une fois
moi
+ moi
en plus tous ceux qui le
suis tu sors
entrer dans la tente
mais c'est
la scission
ma chance aux ide
suite
change pas
ça va
tous ceux qui le
[Musique]
seule année
en traitant
la dent
n'est ce pas là
ce qui de
on est
[Musique]
ceux qui ne veulent me suis plus elle
est
tout ce qu'ils ont
à la danse à lui
ce qui me va
suit
mais m
salut
genre toi plus moi plus tous ceux qui le
veulent puissent lui puis cela et tout
ce qui s'ensuit
allez venez
on est entré dans la danse jamais
est entré dans la danse merci
[Applaudissements]
le louvre
[Musique]
merci des voix
[Applaudissements]
c'est un amour de mettre au sport
catalan sionnel et l'album
lorsque vous la cades est formidable
merci ma chérie dame
la matière
un peu
voilà
alors malgré ça va tu tu me reconnais tu
me connais pas bah moi je vous regarde
beaucoup sur touche pas à mon poste
et bah je trouve très rigolo pour
commencer nous non
gros bisous merci d'avoir été là et les
enfants vous êtes exceptionnel mais
j'adore ce qu'il fait est mauvais c'est
vraiment un dernier coup de jeune à la
folie et que vous le voir ce soir voilà
qui voulait verser avec l'eau à
l'intérieur d'un bus qui part la mort
parce que c'est vrai qu'on vit des
moments difficiles et grâce à des
artistes comme grégoire vraiment on
passe d'excellents moments et gris
bourse et la grâce à toi je sais comme
je t'aime chérie mais moi si et un jour
je te laisserais même gagné au ping pong
[Applaudissements]
allez ce soir c'est que de l'amour sur
invités oui c'est un prime spécial on
est en direct on avait vraiment envie
d'être avec vous et c'est que de l'amour
pour vous c'est que de l'amour pour les
chroniqueurs parce qu'il y aura plein de
surprise pour vous et j'aurai plein
d'image à vous montrez vous avez préparé
même des choses pour nos téléspectateurs
inversion en direct mais pour l'instant
pour moi dans la chronique de camille
sée que de la galère alors on a un
enfant de stars est un enfant de star
c'est encore mokhtar qui a fauté mokhtar
voilà qui est alors mokhtar vrai qu'il a
un succès incroyable nos chances on est
motard et à chaque fois les fans me
disent qu'est-ce qu'il est beau ce
motard non mais c'est vrai qu'on me dit
les sexy les baux est encore plus beau
en vrai et donc vous vous le voyez à la
télé vous le trouvez beau mais en vrai
c'est encore quelqu'un d'autre si tu
veux plus parler
pour bernard trouvé l'enfant de stars
donc de mokhtar et dany boon il a
participé à un jeu cette semaine
regardez vous avez cassé qui a peu
brillé en jouant aux billes
tendanciellement et et là c'est le
moment que vous attendez aussi on vous
l'avait promise
c'est la nouvelle danse la nouvelle le
dollar moderne alors juste avant de la
voir ce que c'est la nouvelle danse de
l'amour de matthieu delormeau alors si
vous nous rejoignez seulement ce soir
sachez que matthieu delormeau et fans
bien sûr de médias il est fan de
voitures de cuir exclusif également de
danse et matthieu delormeau vous donne
des cours de danse accompagnée de
camille et de bertrand toutes les
semaines et cette semaine c'est la danse
de l'amour est juste avant qu'on regarde
cette non je voudrais rappeler quand
même l'album un bond de meyer qui est
sorti aujourd'hui qui cartonne un
vraiment un monde meilleur c'est l'album
de kids united alors
[Musique]
à
en tant qu'ami bon camilla de leurs
modèles nouvelles de leurs modèles
évidemment comme toute cette émission
sous le signe de l'amour au mathieu a pu
inviter les gens qu'il aimait voilà
c'est une grande de leur modèle si vous
apprendra à séduire et à aimer les
autres il ya encore et encore des
surprises dans cette de l'hormone est ce
qu'il ya des gens qu'on n'attendait pas
qui sont dedans à tout à fait c'est
vraiment c'est mathieu a eu là je lui ai
laissé vraiment les clés en main voilà
ce que ça donne une de leurs mots dance
médine mathieu de l'homme
[Musique]
kikou les boys and girls déjà le
cinquième toute hausse de la deûle en
mode nc aujourd'hui une de leur mode and
special amour spéciales loeb
on a tous besoin non corrigée croire
j'appelle les bassins est
koukougnon camille coucou ou bertrand où
j'en connais un qui revient de vacances
allaient tous leurs modèles
alors on démarre les garçons 5 6 7 on se
retourne en garde loin devant red carpet
et la 7 pouces un câlin qu'est-ce qui
fait le poussin il a les pieds en canard
piou piou piou piou piou piou piou a les
attentions c'est le french love love
allez c'est parti ouais le sourire le
sourire bravo mon bertrand tu la forme
et on voyage un petit peu maintenant
l'amour est universel il me semble c'est
la vahiné du love il fait beau et on
s'aime ouais ouais
deux modèles ont fini comment on s'offre
attention oui voilà de leurs modèles
alors c'est le drame de l'amour c'est le
prix de l'offre
j'ai une petite surprise pour vous je
vais appeler deux de mes petits choux
qui sont avec nous ce soir comme un
coucou
alors oui je voulais te dire un truc a
déjà je suis super contente ici pas là
de leur modèle et j'ai pensé à un pas
qui pourrait intéresser alors t'es
gentil tu penses à rien du tout comme
d'habitude ici et sur d8 vous êtes
sûrement un territoire vous avez compris
que ça veut dire
j'ai explosé sur des 8 et oui il faudra
s'y faire sachez qu'ici c'est chez moi
déjà à nina il lui reste quoi joue deux
trois mois d'existence sur cette chaîne
ensuite ce sera touche pas à madame ans
et avec qui bibi phoques alors que
j'étais bien en excuse moi mais qu'est
ce que tu peux me re expliqué le
retourne à gacé
mais ce que c'est pénible de devoir
faire ses gaules en permanence la jambe
gauche a regardé les braises communion
bien et on se retourne c'est compliqué
ça je crois pas non de leurs modèles
hier toute la france dans ces cinq six
sept musique
[Musique]
yeah
los bravos bertrand et surtout bravo
chez vous applaudissez vous embrassez
vous c'est la de l'art moderne ou là de
leur moulin
on se retrouve sans gâteau 6e tu toast
la de leurs modèles
[Applaudissements]
la de la rondelle
à
[Musique]
elle
mais chérie je vous le dis matthieu
delormeau
vous n'êtes pas au bout de vos surprises
dans ce spécial amour on a une
magnifique surprise pour vous dans un
instant
surprise touche pas à mon poste entendu
avant conditions je pense que ça va vous
faire plaisir quand même camille juste à
vous partiez vous trouvera qu'un mec ici
autour de la table ça fait combien de
temps maintenant que vous soyez ça fait
10 as fait six ans qu'on fait l'émission
parce que vous avez sur france 4 ouais
il ya un mec qui n'a pas changé il a
toujours la même gueule il a toujours
été yeux c'est qu'ils camille
franchement caddie j'hésite entre deux
autres chez qui je dirais entre gens me
et christophe entre gens me christophe
bass abdou khadre
[Rires]
c'est bien sûr c'est bien sûr thierry
monde je vous propose est dans l'instant
de revoir thierry moreau et vous allez
voir il n'a pas changé initial et dans
un instant thierry dans l'instant
regardez bien thierry moreau je vous
jure regardez bien parce que là thierry
moreau ce sera plus le même
philippe vous ne le reconnaître et plus
vous verrez vous n'allez plus
reconnaître thierry moreau on va
s'occuper de lui vous êtes rassuré non
chérie vous ne bougez pas on va se
retrouver dans un instant c'est un prime
spécial c'est que de l'amour merci
d'être avec nous ce soir on est en
direct dans un instant s'occupe de
thierry moreau et juste après il y aura
votre surprise
weekes remerciements aux manchots
agrafes émetteurs un espace camille
service qui s'occupe de tout ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les jets deux oiseaux et mehdi c'est ce
qui a plu ce serait bénéfique
les ailes des oiseaux gilbert et on
reprend toutes les belles chansons
françaises
il reprend toutes les chansons avec un
accent tunisien au mari si tu savais sur
la tête de ma mère et à lumières allumez
le feu pas trop fort quand même un mec
fait des commentaires dans les chansons
seraient alors les chéris merci d'être
avec nous une étape ans après une
spéciale on voulait absolument être avec
vous aujourd'hui et les cherry on
voulait vous parler d'amour ce soir
puisque c'est que d'amour acheta que
c'est que d'abord il ya plein de gens
qui réagissent sans bien sûr sur twitter
et sur facebook et vous nous laissez
plein de messages prenez des photos les
cherry et envoyez nous envoyez nous une
petite faute aussi les petites photos
avec des coeurs comme ça rien tout
public folle guerre voilà moi j'ai du
mal à le faire parce que j'ai des lois
le pourri sinon vous pouvez le faire
chez vous alors il ya plein de surprises
qui vont arriver je vous le dis on va
revoir un plein d'image vous montrer
plein d'image d'amour et aussi il ya des
surprises pour vous autour de la table
des belles surprises comme vous les
aimez valérie benaïm je m'occupais de
vous dans un instant je m'occupais de
matthieu delormeau ci qui aura une belle
surprise pour le moment
on parlait de thierry moreau thierry
moreau alors thierry moreau c'est bien
simple
thierry moreau regardez le il est frais
il est frais pour son iphone en france
il est membre
freddy pas le gouffre alors regardez
alors thierry ça fait combien de temps
qu'on travaille ensemble ça va faire six
en disant non mais ça fait six ans oui
et ce qui manque ce qui m'interpelle
c'est votre éternelle vieillesse effet
un captage a plus bougé si ça en fait
vous vous avez nommé c'est vrai vous
avez toujours été view non mais vraiment
on ne connaît pas sa tête jaune ça c'est
fou et regardez jour outre un petit un
petit magnéto de thierry moreau et vous
allez voir qu'il n'a pas changé et ce
soir on va s'en occuper et thierry
moreau vous allez retrouver mais
vraiment c'est pas un relooking
c'est un relooking extrême regardez un
plaisir vous êtes le plus chic de
l'émission euros oui je me suis dit
qu'il mettait une cravate je me démarque
comme un petit peu tout le monde vous
vous démarquez je vous le confirme j'ai
mis trois semaines à comprendre que
c'était une émission face il ya dormi
c'est rachida téléspectateurs il a un
col ça déconne et on dirait une feuille
de papier a4 sortait une colle à la dany
brillant comme ça le jour
quel regard là on n'est pas bien du tout
au niveau coiffure à non mais là ça
aurait volé l'annoncé ne sait pas où on
va mais on y va droit dans le mur
c'est n'importe quoi on dirait que vous
avez un temps projette sur la tête non
mais ça on dirait que vous allez récurer
d'aidé d'un évier la non mais c'est pas
possible j'ai ri moreau motion
il n'a pas changé on est d'accord il n'a
pas changé alors les chéris auto
d'ailleurs je rappelle que c'est que de
l'amour donc même si vous dites une
saloperie faut dire c'est que l'amour
d'ailleurs oui c'est pas parce qu'on
s'aime énormément qu'il faut se mentir
quand même pays depuis toujours et
dégueulasse mais c'est comme ça que de
l'amour qui est appelée box a lâché dès
les séries d'ailleurs je lance tout de
suite le hashtag plein de folie à lacets
robert redford il me parla là ça
rigolait tout de suite vous y allez vous
mettez un petit commentaire
là on a dit catherine gil dicaprio s'est
alors thierry thierry je vous dit vous
savez que j'ai pas l'habitude de laisser
les chroniqueurs dans la détresse
et ce soir j'ai décidé de m'occuper de
vous thierry vous allez passer toutes
les missions relooking extrême
il est exactement ce que nous sommes en
direct il est exactement 21h42 vous
reviendrez tout à l'heure pour les cas
tiers de jean luc lemoine et bousserez
une autre personne
thierry moreau puisque brigitte de louis
une experte des cas vraiment compliqué
brigitte est là alors brigitte elle est
formidable c'est elle qui a fait le
grand bluff avec patrick sébastien c'est
une très grosse et nokia ont la dorothy
lamour de fans alors vous allez aller la
rejoindre et non seulement elle va vous
mettre tout nu mais en plus mais elle va
tout refaire du sol au plafond
j'ai voté
on reverra on reverra thierry mots en
fin d'émission mais quand je vous dis ça
va être une autre personne mais vraiment
vous allez voir vous n'avez pas le
reconnaître je pense que vraiment mais
ça va faire du bien sa femme aussi
qu'elle va laisser un message et elle
est au bout du rouleau masse les chéris
juste je voudrais qu on est on est des
images qui vous ont marqué d'amour voilà
dans touche pas à mon poste ou bien dans
d'autres émissions parce que j'ai aussi
des images d'amour d'autres émissions
enora elle voulait commencer par vous
voulez une image qui vous a marqué les
l'image d'amour de touche pas à mon
poste c'est quoi pour faire mes moments
préférés c'était y'a pas si longtemps
c'était le 24 septembre pour fêter votre
anniversaire au lieu qu'on vous place
des cadeaux que vous avez décidé de
refaire au public et vous avez amené
tout le monde dans un grand parc
d'attractions je propose de revoir les
images et de revivre cette émotion est
juste après jour il annonce pour le
public et pour vous également chez vous
parce qu'on a une petite surprise
regardez donc ce soir je vais partir je
vais partir avec
avec cette personne je vais partir avec
vous madame je partais avec vous avec
vous avec elle aussi tu veux partir je
vais partir avec elle aussi répartir
avec elle l'a fait partir avec elle
aussi je porterai avec lui bah les gars
je vais partir avec tout le public les
chéris on va partir tous ensemble
les fier de l'aider car voilà
on va partir avec tout le public avec
vous les chroniqueurs et on va partir
pour une soirée de folie on va faire la
fête toute la nuit on va dormir là bas
[Applaudissements]
et vous dit elora cadeau pour tout le
public en fin d'émission à messieurs si
ça c'est pas de l'amour et d'orages ou
dit le cadeau ce sera pas tout à fait la
même chose qu'on a explosé le budget
mais tu auras un autre cadeau pour le
public avant la part la mission tous les
publics partir avec un cadeau d'accord
pas il partira pas avec ce que vous
verrez
[Applaudissements]
ok
oh
issa doumbia
je suis passé est-ce que là pourquoi il
est passé ça tout l'amour et et je ne
suis pas là comment ça s'est fait aussi
de déplacer de chez moi pour venir
aujourd'hui je m'en fous ça s'il vous
plaît t'inquiète pas je vais faire ma
place touchait alors vous lie à cette
émission ça va être un être la police
arrête n'importe quoi on est en direct
on avait vraiment envie d'être avec vous
ce soir ce qu'il fait avec sa tétine mm
fizi debout lettre tue à l'assemblée ben
c'est pas le moment c'est pas le bon pas
le moment mais si ses lames ou à la page
et m j'aime bien ça vous va très bien en
tout cas leurs cieux de tremblant oui ça
me va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tous à vos souris puisque vous êtes live
ça est-ce que vous avez un mot d'amour
pour chacun des chroniques lorsque j'ai
intégré l'équipe pour vous il aime tout
le monde moi j'aime bien les coups de
gueule dès mon petit gilles verdez même
si on sait qu'au fond de lui c'est un
valdès original koudou tout cas qu'un
gel aime bien beau jour de ma petite
honnorat oui c'est votre action oui
c'est parce que je suis un hdj du jeu
wild je suis tombé dedans mais je donne
ma petite ennahda même si on dirait la
dédain des pitbulls lagarde a vraiment
motivé le petit roi lion mac en stérols
ac toi la zone amont pour qui au corry
ça pour tout le monde j'ai de mon pour
toute la forêt située à d'accord je vous
demanderais leur détention
cette fois de l'amour c'est soir qui ont
démis bavard plein de surprises arrêts
tu vas faire une bêtise
voilà cette affaire je pense que c'est
bien ce que je pensais merci en tout cas
pour la merguez à isabelle morini-bosc
je tiens à vous c'est quoi l'image
d'amour que vous retournez de touche
touche pas à mon poste à demain mais on
a laissé faire des âneries à may en a
une que j'ai adoré finalement vous
m'avez le jour de la saint patrick
je les ai vus c'est là qu'on voit là on
a tous retrouvé notre prof de sciences
naturelles
alors ça c'est sûr que les élèves sur
dix ils m'ont offert d adrian les joyeux
drilles que vous étiez oh là là haut les
loustics alors qu'est ce qu'on a fait et
bien le jour de la saint-patrick kef et
irlandaise donc des roues oui vous
m'avez envoyé chercher un roux dans la
rue de préférence le soir quand il y
avait personne mais c'est vrai et donc
je suis entré dans un restaurant je veux
un américain un ancien roues et il m'a
montré une photo il était vraiment rond
avant tout cas du haut et bas vous avez
déjà vu des mecs qui sont roux que dura
c'est les mecs qu'ils ont une carotte à
la place du zizi quoi on n'oublie pas il
fait raser en tout cas le haut était
bien roues avant et il était magnifique
et je les ramener avec moi le pauvre il
a attendu 45 minutes avec moi du coup on
en a pris langue si je veux dire rien
autre rookie nous avons entendu un jeune
qui est descendue du coup je suis revenu
avec un roux autrefois roues et un jeune
roues et ça a été magnifique et il ya
une jeune fille rousse plaquer mais non
sans cynisme
merci notre magnifique ça va franchement
c'est que de l'amour et de la franchise
ce soir qui a envie après cette
description de revoir les images ici
gilles non mais non mais non elle est
tellement gentil ça va lui faire plaisir
c'est aux amoureux quelqu'un le voit et
pu demander de me renvoyer ses
coordonnées mais je les ai perdus elles
veulent pêcher
vous avez vraiment craqué sur l'île à m
envoyer d'autres trucs
après non mais bien de quoi il vous
avait alors ajouté des petits mots aqmi
en anglais ça veut dire c'est moi la
paix intérieure
demandez vous n'avez pas roussi pour un
jeu vous n'avez personne de roux ici
[Rires]
why ou même de forts j'ai un monsieur
qui a été calé theroux c'est bon il est
consentant en plus il entend aider vous
plaît ou pas il vous plait oui beaucoup
mais les camions rouges
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un parce que la
production vous avez quand même bien ou
d'un débat c'est vous pas du tout moi
j'habite à côté là non c'est pas vrai on
me dit que c'est pas du tout la personne
[Applaudissements]
j'habite à côté quand j'ai entendu quand
j'ai entendu la bien le micro quand j'ai
entendu l'avion je suis descendu chez
moi si votre non pas du tout mes jeux
[Applaudissements]
et l'auteur de l'amour alors avant
d'avoir la surprise pour matthieu
delormeau ils sachent que vous avez un
petit mot gentil pour isabella pour
valérie bénaïm valérie benaïm je
voudrais deux jours mangé des boulettes
ou le soir toutes les nuits et je serai
taboulé alors valérie valérie valérie
vous savez que vous avez tous les talons
on vous a vu ou jouer au piano comme
personne
regardez ce sont en tout cas si vous
découvrez les missions et que vous
connaissez pas valérie benaïm c'est une
virtuose du piano mais valérie bénaïm
vous avez un autre talent mais non vous
un drap talents d'ici si si vous avez un
autre talent valérie benaïm vous avez
vraiment un autre talent et je vous le
dis ce talent on l'a appris de quelqu'un
qui vous est très très proches quelqu'un
qui vous voit tous les jours quelqu'un
qui vous aime quelqu'un qui partage
votre lit mais non mais n'importe où
cette personne
son prénom commence par un ppj lien à
metz il ya une poche à personne c'est
patoche patoche nous a révélé que vous
saviez faire quelque chose nous pas du
tout un talent caché et vous savez faire
quelque chose avec vous avec vos pieds
quoi vous allez vous faisait quelque
chose d'incroyable avec vos pieds jean
michel vous avez une idée neuve
oui mais non merci
[Rires]
farmiga
valérie bénaïm mais quoi regardez mon
échangé notre échange de textos avec
fait des claquettes avez vous des photos
j'ai récupéré l'info auprès de sa
famille elle en a fait mais ça n'a duré
que quelques semaines elle avait à peine
8 ans hélas pas de photos de cette
malheureuse expérience
désolé valérie bénaïm est une championne
de claquettes et regardez ce que j'ai
ici
[Applaudissements]
remy jean attention valérie benaïm vous
allez vous faire une démonstration de
claquettes
il ya une troupe qui va venir nous
rejoindre allez vous alors mettez moi ça
le temps qu'on regarde donc ça qu'on
regarde l'image d'amour préféré de deux
de matthieu delormeau alors bon mathieu
un bon mathieu vous l'image qui vous a
le plus marqué l'image d'amour dans
touche pas à mon poste c'est quoi c'est
particulier parce que c'est le début de
quelque chose
en tout cas pour moi et je pense aussi
peut-être pour vous mais vous êtes trop
pudique pour le dire en tout cas fait
très peur lui non votre maman a
peut-être vu des choses que vous n'avez
pas encore vu car vous êtes bloc du
coeur sans doute donc j'ai du coeur sans
doute ça a été la fois où j'ai été
hypnotisé voyez en réalité ses adieux
révéler quelque chose et donc je vous ai
trouvé extrêmement beau séduisant qu'est
ce qu'il ya mathieu on va regarder se
magner tout juste après ouais je vous
posais une question il va falloir me
répondre franchement toujours c'est
toujours tout dit ici ouais on regarde
c'est votre amour à gérer d'accord ouais
t'es dans la merde
or aller sur le banc voire d'amour qu'a
choisi matthieu delormeau regarder ce
que le réalisateur veut juste un plot
matthieu delormeau matthieu delormeau
fait très peur cette doit pas vous êtes
beau dit mathieu chaque émission vous
êtes plus beau que la précédente ce qui
se passe mais c'est bien et quand vous
mettez une veste verte et cravate c'est
bien parce qu on est à la fois dans le
divertissement mais dans le
dans la lune ou à l'halloween sais pas
je connaisse à un ami il est beau il est
beau
oui lebouc moi non vous êtes très beau
mais je pense de plus beau des
animateurs c'est frédérique bel et beau
oui mais c'est vous tous vous avez du
charme
ouais j'avais du charisme à merci c'est
vrai vous êtes très beau quand ça me
gênait le coup mathieu de l'enfant qui
m'aide a rejoint cette année mathieu
j'ai une vraie question à vous poser
vous me donnerez la réponse juste après
la valérie bénaïm qui va nous faire sa
démonstration de claquettes
venez avec moi ici sur le centre scène
et valérie déjà dévoilé elle a tous les
talents que dieu bénisse
par contre on april de taille en dessous
une jeune âge dedans mais vous nagez
dedans mais vous avez l'habitude de
nager
merci je me mêle valérie bénaïm vous
n'allez pas faire des claquettes tout
seul puisqu'il y a un collectif de
danseurs qui est à dire s'ils allaient
me si je vous jure que c'est vrai les
enfants qui vont vous venez donnez les
séries
alors attention
mais thébaux centre valérie bénaïm alors
les chéris comment s'appelle votre
groupe laissant pas de luan
c'est apparemment ces enfants ne sortent
pas de l'hygiène on les ajuste recueilli
justement avant l'émission et joue la
ligue des merci l'aïd et donc il ya
quelques hisser dois le dire à mes
autres ne savent pas du tout va les
réveiller parce que vous pouvez vous
mettre à côté de cette jeune bien sûr il
est au centre des attentions alors
valérie verhée il me veut faire des
copies dans fait un attention valérie
bénaïm ces partis mais l'est elle me
suivent
oui alors regardez alors attend d'abord
j'aimerais qu'on voit zus valérie
mesdames et messieurs seul d'accord vous
ne faites rien pour l'instant tout seul
mettez de la musique
allez-y valérie aînés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
non
et
[Applaudissements]
les chefs
mathieu lavoie est ce que est ce que tu
peux me rappeler l'école de danse comme
un label made in là idée est toujurs je
crois que c'est l'école de danse de ma
fille non bianca quai dans cette école
de danse voilà et voilà donc c'est vrai
on va vous connaissez pas ma fille cl
l'arrêt voilà c'est bien qu'à voilà qui
doit qui doit accoucher mais qui nous
regardera demain et voilà les chéris
bravo à vous merci et bravo
ça ne s'était pas courir mais pas si mal
pas si mal
c'est bien guelmim silva sur al valérie
bénaïm matthieu delormeau
mais j'ai un truc à vous dire matthieu
delormeau on vous a vu dans cette
émission spéciale it au cinéma non mais
elle s'est tue tchad à l'ats la cheffe
des truqueurs benhaim salia et au fond
c'est la ouarzazate est là avec moi en
vacances aller tranquille mathieu
j'avais été plus petits zay et donc
l'hypnotiseur vous avez fait vous a fait
devenir amoureux de moi j'ai
l'impression
et franchement je ne suis pas le seul à
avoir ce sentiment
j'ai la forte impression que vous êtes
réellement amoureux de moi alors j'ai
fait n'être pas l'aude pour ça mais
j'aimerais aujourd'hui pour les
téléspectateurs pour nous c'est que de
l'amour ce soit j'aimerais vraiment que
vous disiez les choses est ce que oui ou
non vous m'aimez avec un grand m
comme à sa scène rico jean oury est
maintenant divisée que ce stream senti
la voix qua non musique de suspense et
nouvelle star
merci en régie vous êtes parti merci ils
sont ils sont 100 original à pain qui a
suivi des missions
merci toujours un petit décalage
honnêtement oui parce que sinon on
l'entend pas le petit déjeuner non mais
honnêtement
c'est vrai vous me trouble et beaucoup à
la vache beaucoup de charme beaucoup de
charme sa tête beau gosse et c'est vrai
que j'ai envie de répondre oui et même
je pense que vous même je vous sens
troublé
[Applaudissements]
cyril et je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
hasard
ah si si quand pas vous m'appelez le
dimanche que je suis dans le bain ça
peut pas être un hasard
toi beaucoup estiment de la vie ah oui
je ne donne jamais acheté quand j'ai dit
alors vous m'appelez je vous dis je suis
dans le bain pour aider je vous rappelle
pas du tout vous continuez qu'est-ce
qu'il fait dimanche que tu fais tout à
l'heure voilà je pense tout bas il t-il
pas je sais pas alors après peut-être
que je me trompe
oui oui alors je je je je je peux
répondre à talons je joue je vous aime
beaucoup
non mais vous vous êtes vous êtes
amoureux de mode par amitié comment
annoncer à un petit quelque chose en
plus ah oui un petit quelque chose en
plus ça va ça vous trouble pas un petit
peu alors ça ne me trouve pas ça
m'angoisse ben qu'oui gilles je crois
qu'il n'a pas été déprogrammé en fait
ouais c'est vrai merci aux gars fait
selva des trois semaines j'ai pas grave
pas vous suit les passe par la vérité
vous par exemple qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous ressentez mathieu y à
il ya deux semaines tu m'a appelé
j'étais dans mon bain oui j'en ai pas
déduite tu voulais mais choquant mais la
raison va paraître bizarre mais vous
dans le bar vous êtes non je suis bien
dans mon bar tué le gardien truqués 13
escalade ou vous nous appelez aussi
quand vous fait caca déduire à mois par
mois ne vous en appelez certains
managers très très visible mais je le
dis et ce soir c'est spécial c'est que
de l'amour c'est une preuve d'amour et
d'amitié ça je vous le dis jolie alors
mathieu pour vous répondre
merci déjà de votre amour parce que
l'amour se refuse pas c'est un cadeau il
faut vous dire quand on vous offre un
cadeau au louvre et bougez vous ne sont
pas
et bien c'est bien de venir les choses
entrebâillé la porte non non non non non
non si l'autre by laporte qui peut
passer le pied autre chose et je ne veux
pas que ça bien entendu mais mathieu je
prends ce cadeau et je le laisse de côté
je le laisse à la caf et et mais moi
vous avez toute mon amitié est vraiment
amicalement vous me trouble et vous êtes
une des personnes que je préfère dans
l'équipe sachez que met d'accord
vraiment vous êtes dans le top 12 de mes
préférés lag énormément maman je
l'aimais lent mais c'est vrai vous avez
battu encore une fois bravo pour votre
franchise et si vous partez sur nrj 12
eh ben je peux vous dire pour moi ce
sera la loose détecte alors c'est bon
allez merci
alors les chéris juste on a l'image de
thierry moreau c'est vous qui avez
l'image de thierry morin de la marque et
justement si c'était en décembre 2012 on
recevait ce moment là emmanuel moire et
fauve hautot à l'occasion d'un numéro de
danse avec les stars et et thierry avait
eu cette phrase fantastique est resté
une des phrases cultes touche pas à mon
poste était on a toujours le temps
d'aimer et ça va donner lieu du coup à
une explosion de canal en tout public
c'était vous je vous trouve de mieux en
mieux on a tout compris et ça fait
combien de temps que fait la télé bas
depuis le temps visant je pense que dans
dix quinze ans il ya beaucoup de stars
qui viennent ici d'ailleurs dans
d'autres émissions qui disent qu'ils
n'ont pas le temps on a dit on a
toujours le temps d'aimer koren
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était un accent moto on a toujours le
temps d'aimer tiens si vous aviez vous
chacun une phrase une phrase sur l'amour
ce serait laquelle puisque c'est que de
l'amour ce soir voilà c'est complètement
improvisé un donc je vous laisse
quelques secondes
bien sûr pour réfléchir ils sont tous en
galère sur twitter et sur facebook
hashtags et que de l'amour est juste
après ce petit tour de table
j'aurai une surprise pour vous en votre
surprise matthieu delormeau votre
surprise c'est que de l'amour est là ça
va vous faire très très très plaisir je
vous le dis vraiment alors vous mercredi
à me roy votre votre phrase voilà ce à
quoi m e mois des tests mois mais
surtout regarde-moi priscilla 2002 aide
moi il est est moi oublie moi
[Applaudissements]
besson
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
attention
oh
merci merci merci et bravo bravo merci à
vous et vous avez fait revivre la régie
mais sans déconner bravo c'était les
mots donc on sera maintenant les mots
pour refaire vivre la régie m mois des
tests mois reste deux mois
voilà c'est dit voila voila il va les
lib-dems qui est ton commentaire toutes
les nanas
alors vous c'est quoi votre phrase est
bien une vie sans amour c'est comme un
couscous 100 bullets n'a pas d'intérêt à
mal vous êtes toujours focus
alors j'attends vous parce que je sens
que j'arrête un festival moi c'est une
france qu'on m'a dit qu'un amoureux
madian à jamais à toi à jamais à moi à
jamais à new as well as jamais à toi à
jamais à moi à jamais non oui pas mal ça
monte un sortait avec baudelaire
franchement quatrième talhouët à vous
l'amour c'est mieux à deux au moins deux
à wes herrett par toulouse c'est de
dominique strauss kahn
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'amour j'ai pas les moyens
c'est jean michel maire alors oui vous
t'aimer c'est admirer avec le coeur tu
admires et c'est aimer avec l'esprit est
ce que vous aimeriez parce qu'il ya
sauté le nom dean qui m'a parlé dans
l'oreillette
je la refais elysées dans l'azur thé
mais c'est admirer avec le coeur tu
admirais 7 et mais avec l'esprit et
c'est avec moi c'est chiant la tête de
ma mère j'ai l'impression d'être en bac
philo j'ai eu une montée de race car
j'ai cru qu'un apple allait rajouter à
fait gérable je ramasse les copies dans
d'autres
regarde quel en bois selma michel a
alors vous jean michel maire c'est une
belle phrase de saint texte qui fait un
texte
[Applaudissements]
tu as lu lé nouveau saint-ex sept
accusés c'est un texte dit moi je vais
te citer cette phrase de saint-ex
travailler avec bhv
bernard henri iv nice alors il donc
c'est quoi la phrase saint-exupéry avait
dit l'amour c'est regarder tous les deux
dans la même direction belge auquel cas
je réponds non ça c'est la levrette
mais où vous avez eu autant de réfléchir
on ensuite le hashtag super lourd mais
c'est un truc de fou passé le plus
lourdes aux christophe carrière ben moi
je citerai un très grand philosophe
saint-ex non non non c'est bien
nietzsche qui n'ont françois valéry et
bizet aimons-nous vivant c'est bon c'est
ça je peux si je peux dire un truc je
vous aime beaucoup les deux l'a fait à
chaque fois simple pas d'humour
vraiment non mais non mais si vous aimez
vraiment ne fait pas dans l'humour qui
me manque de mon hymne à l'amour c'est
un voyage sort le tour sauf si tu as une
carte de séjour
[ __ ]
attention j'ai mon cousin babacar qui
est si bas car nous regarde où es-tu où
es tu on se comprend des tutelles je
serai l'amour à ton âme je venais
software regardez regardez où vous
voulez mais pas moi en plus j'ai
l'impression que votre mii de pointe à
la raison et à l'isi a le feraient
l'amour à ton âme je vénérais ton coeur
et je m'étendrai sur ton corps mais
c'est sinon attendez laissez le td
reprenait sky avait une suite pardon non
j'avais presque fini non et je foulerai
aux piétons corps jusqu'à en faire des
parties les pêches jean crampes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est quoi cette bonne voie cette amende
est enfin attendent à la phrase siens du
bellâtre tubes et mettez moi tu peux te
plaindre au petit bois quelque chose
pour accompagner le magicien le magicien
de l'amour
le magicien d'nrj12 vous dans un instant
vous nous donnerez votre phrase de
l'amour dans un instant j'ai une
surprise pour vous j'ai déjà bien vous
la donnerais l'instant mon verdict tombe
ou incroyable matthieu delormeau
je sais pas si ça vous faire plaisir
mais une chose est sûr c'est qu'à vous
chez vous ça va vous faire marrer a tout
de suite sur des bus
[Applaudissements]
on voulait pas vous lâcher on voulait
pas que vous nous lâcher ce soir et on
voulait être avec vous un coeur pour
vous c'est que de l'avoir y en a bien
besoin d'amour en ce moment j'espère
vous passer un bon moment avec nous sur
d8 en famille pour regarder cette
émission ont bouffé des normes disions
ici à vue pour tous les coeurs vous
continuez c'est que de l'amour sur
twitter et on en a plein plein plein
plein plein de messages merci les chiens
regarder voilà eh ben on nous voit
derrière eux ban dans un coeur j'ai une
belle gueule de con là les chéris bocoum
a plein de choses à faire et je voudrais
vraiment remercier
on est très heureux d'être avec vous ce
soir vous pouvez pas savoir voilà on
voulait absolument être là et j'espère
que vous aussi vous passez un mauvais
moment
il se tourna table y aura une surprise
pour le public dans un instant il y aura
aussi j'ai complètement oublié je crois
qu'un voyage à gagner un voyage à gagner
à la saint-amour voilà donc le hashtag
le je ne le connais pas mais il va
s'inscrire au bas de votre écran et on
appellera quelqu'un avant la fin de
l'émission ils sont en train de chercher
le hashtag origine je n'ai plus du tout
personne en régie donc apparemment ils
sont contre sont à leur phase i à la
pizzeria voilà donc ça fait plaisir
s'ils sont chez aldo dit aldo de nous
appeler voilà de la pizzeria voilà on me
dit dans la régie hashtag tomate mozza
ils me disent qu'ils ont commandés
[Rires]
on peut dire hashtag http mp saint-amour
alors on en parlait d'amour il ya un
instant je vois pas que thierry moreau
est partie thierry moreau pour appeler
tirer mais aucun n'a une faute au tir et
moraux regarder la tête de thierry
moreau merci on l'a pas là merci j on
n'a plus rien à perdre je vais vous lire
passé 22h22 bandar quelque chose
voilà donc thierry moreau on a décidé de
complètement le relooker et vous allez
voir vous n'allez pas le reconnaître
vous le verrez dans un instant on aille
également jean-luc lemoine qui va nous
rejoindre pour les questions en 4/3 et
oui ça ça va être du très très bon et
pour le moment ya une surprise pour vous
matthieu delormeau mais juste avant vous
avez demandé une petite phrase sur
l'amour je stresse de ma surprise alors
rarement bonnec vous excusez moi j'ai
pas le temps
alors si vous permettez ces deux mois ah
oui louis saez nous amènera les nuits et
des nuits dabul avait lui il a une
pastèque mais c'est réglé
l'amour oui c'est comme une ferrari 430
scuderia
ça me prend de la valeur avec le temps
c'est nanterre franchement je vous dis
on peut pas rester sur ça vous savez
alors vous avez une demi-heure pour
trouver c'est de la merde oui vous avez
tranquille qui arrêtaient c'est trop tôt
et le bon bah ouais la lave en direct le
match à pattaya
[Musique]
ouais c'est bon et qui est presque à
jean-michel petit dylan qui dit quoi
c'est un fait rare il a su se parle je
vais rentrer chez moi
il parle automobile rétro les gens
n'aiment dernière non non alors attendez
c'est la très belle à huy elle n'est pas
de moi mais travail commun aller pas de
vous et de petits même la très courte
saint-ex n'est pas séparée d'avec ses
nerfs ce rap saïan zeit écoutez bien
mais c'est lui qui m'a lancé rien je
peux vous dire un auteur c'est vous
c'est du talent aux soeurs qui bat
martin lamartine ses lunettes saint
martin et on embrasse à françois loos
chantal et et pas plus haut que nature
ni la branche lembras la partie droite
chantal et n'oubliez pas de déplacer
déjà fait parce qu'elles viennent
d'entrer des icebergs
[Musique]
ajouter la bien déjà toi là tu me fais
pas ça un oui alors oui si les moyens
venant c'est sa femme sur les scellés
merci à l'esa et les trois là bas là ils
se sont elles se soient habillés quoi
exergue au plus grand cabaret du monde
sans femmes sur la tête de la mer elle a
sorti la robe du mariage
peaufinant ses joueurs on va faire la
fête
alors vos trois d'amour celle de leur
niveau l'amour c'est ne plus comparé ces
pourris c'est trop l'humanisation chance
à ces au chaud show en direct du tout et
pourquoi pas avec l'amour je positive
nous la fin d'année amusant trouver une
autre c'est pour y est pour rien c'est
pourri c'est pour idia sa spéciale à
bourg ce soir mais juste par plaisir
avant de vous donner votre surprise vous
trouviez votre surprise qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui a souhaité vous faire une
surprise car cette surprise et humaine
ah oui vous allez voir vous allez
pouvoir trouver j'allais devoir trouver
qui est venu vous faire une surprise ce
soir
d'accord c'est une énorme surprise pour
vous juste avant j'aurais juste qu'on
voit parce que pour moi la plus belle
preuve d'amour y en a eu deux c'est jean
michel et isabelle qui les ont faites
dans cette émission
isabelle c'était acquis et à gilles
verdez est vraiment pour moi
là il y avait de l'amour dans ce ta
gueule regardez pas ce que je suis ce
père hésitante mais je suis au service
de la collectivité est ce beauf la
gueule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'était le plus beau de
l'histoire
alors il est en compétition avec un
autre d'ailleurs
là c'était jean-michel est-ce que vous
rappeler c'est à thierry merci
d'ailleurs si vous nous rejoignez vous a
vu que thierry moreau a bien changé
d'abord car il était vraiment excellent
hier soir il y avait 5 me soit 5% de
part de marché on voit que rolling stone
a vraiment marché
alors regardez c'était jean-michel non
mais là je vais raconter comment je
racontais ma femme s'est fait j'étais
jeune journaliste à l'esprit vicat
annonce y aurait des cigarettes et aux
trois hôtesses gold tandis qu la gueule
et du cou
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe qui devait
inciter complètement toute ta gueule du
monde embrasse fort que gérard caddéo
dans l'instant mais vous vous avez peur
vous avez pris beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de gens qui vous parle mal ici
un gildas ont énormément énormément tous
ya quelqu'un qui souhaitait laisser un
petit message à toute l'équipe et
particulièrement avoue gilles regardez
regardez
benjamin salut cyril bravo pour ton
émission pour cette belle idée on a tous
besoin d'amour et c'est vrai que c'est
le moment ou jamais et d'être ensemble
d'être solidaire d'être soudés je peux
pas être là ce soir
messieurs tout coeur avec vous jean race
toute l'équipe et même et même et je
veux dire même surtout s'il gardait soit
là allez bonne édition
ciao
[Applaudissements]
cet erp et s'était appelé très fair play
on oublie tout ce qui a été dit parce
que voilà il ya eu des mots violents de
sa part et de ma part tous à toutes ces
polémiques sont effacées par ce qu'on a
vécu
benjamin je t'embrasse aussi énormément
et je serai très heureux de discuter
sereinement avec toi n'oubliez jamais
les chéris que la télé c'est vraiment
que de la télé qu'elle jouait juste un
autre petit message c'est patrick
sébastien tu sais que de l'amour dit
cyril coucou ben je sais que ce soir tu
vas parler d'amour et pour cause de
tournée je vais pas pour être avec toi
mais tu donnes douter que je regrette de
ne pas être avec toi parce que cet
abandon tu vas parler ça fait des années
que j'en parle je vais pas te faire de
longs discours juste de citer un podium
qui est une de mes phrases de chez
préféré un proverbe chinois qui dit le
pouvoir de l'amour doit toujours être
plus fort que l'amour du pouvoir
voilà je vous fais des gros bisous et je
vous aime beaucoup d'amour on aura
compris que jeanne fort bien prétoire
monteiro monteiro à moi alors doha
d'autres messages vous allez voir mais
pour le moment c'est ch de francky
vincent y dit tu veux mon zizi oui
[Rires]
attendez bravo gonis arrive vous parler
d'amour je crois oui mais il est
toujours là
tiens d'ailleurs benjamin castaldi sera
l'invité touche pas au poste jeudi
prochain un bâtisseur avec moralement
benjamin tient à matthieu delormeau si
on reste ici que ça se passe ça lui
donne à l'autre il est en train de
regarder temps mais c'est le seul cas il
est dense et démissionner comme ça ouais
c'est pas mal hein c'est pas mal le
crépi que vous avez mis la haute et
matthieu delormeau on a une surprise
pour vous il y a quelqu'un qui compte
beaucoup pour l'émission pour touche pas
à mon poste qui a souhaité vous faire
une énorme surprise
vous allez avoir une minute trente pour
trouver qui se cache derrière cette
personne vous pouvez lui poser des
questions et répondra par oui ou par non
regardez cette personne est là c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qu'on aime dans
l'émission allez-y préfecture a les yeux
vous pouvez lui poser des questions
alors j'imagine que c'est un homme oui
on est en écoute oui oui est ce que vous
êtes connus dans le monde alors il à
olemps temps et on entend très mal parce
qu'en fait il est il à manger des chips
est ce que vous êtes un artiste non un
petit peu pour moi un petit peu un petit
peu là dessus c'est un artiste ou est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait de la télévision
non plus non plus tout ce que j'ai déjà
rencontré
est ce que on se connaît torse ne ment
pas persuadé personnellement est ce que
vous vous m'aimez bien ne sais pas je
suis à taxer il vous aime assez oui
d'accord est ce que vous même déjà
rencontré je sache moi j'ai juste une
question posée c'est une question à
toutes les personnes qui travaillent sur
l'émission ou les où l'on est au niveau
du son corps
comment se situe le niveau d'usagé sont
comment la session sur l'échelle de
richter même émission mais m'ont fait
flipper alors elle et d'autres questions
à l'est notre question est ce que vous
êtes jeune oui oui est ce que vous
connaissez quelqu'un dans l'émission non
plus est ce que cette année de cyril non
pas pour moi vous êtes un ami je vous
aime fort avant est ce que vous êtes fan
de l'émission
j'adore à vie qui vous aimez le plus
dans l'émission se compliquer annie
c'est compliqué c'est que c'est gilles
garder à l'égard des à votre avis qui
sait est ce que vous l'avez trouvé en
attendant elle est ronde et le stress
que c'est le cas que j'imite mettez nous
y jean piot ni je crois et nous nous
c'est une question qu est ce qu est ce
qu il
il adore camille combal d'abord oui
d'aucuns j'ai trouvé qui sait oui et
vous sert il est aussi vrai le problème
c'est qu il a un cerveau qui vient tout
nouvel bâlois n'a dit camille combal
camille combal un autre nom revient à un
autre
j'en peux plus de vous anna défaut lieu
donné un 2e et laura masque tient
peut-être là dedans
questerre ou là j'avais pris quelque
chose
la danse j'adore comme moi vous êtes
passionné de danse et vous faites des
chorégraphies exactement du genre il
fait des gorges chaudes qu un collègue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le club star et qui fait les
le modèle de camille combal cessa de
vengeur masqué nu vous dites que ces
crédits which oh oui voilà tracy mucho
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
chan il est là il est avec nous alors
regardez ce que fait créer 800 parce que
dans un instant dans un instant matthieu
delormeau
on va voir un petit magnéto et je vous
dire ce que vous allez faire avec crazy
which shows puisqu'on a envie de voir
quand même une battle de danse
[Applaudissements]
d
[Musique]
mathieu match on est venu de loin
mathieu crazy bicho et là il c'est un
amour de mec vraiment je les aime
énormément et merci à lui d'être venu
mais mathieu vous allez aller rejoindre
crazy which shows et même ça fait pas
fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui vous allez vous
mettre vous allez vous mettre vous allez
voir dans l'instant vous allez revenir
dans la même tenue
recréer which shows on mettra pas
longtemps à vous habiller et mathieu
vous ferez une battle de danse avec
crazy which you ici belge au plateau ça
c'est le clou du spectacle c'est la
floride en menant ce ring c'est la
cerise dans le monde chéri oui monsieur
[Applaudissements]
oui
je vous avais dit qu'il y allait avoir
des surprises et de belles surprises ce
soir vous avez menti je voulais menti
qu'on me jette la première pierre
alors gilles verdez oui vous vous avez
changé proche de bernet vous vous aimez
l'amour c'est un amoureux c'est un
romantique les romantiques sont dans
l'air du temps
les romantiques ont toujours 20 ans
catherine lara et bien depuis des années
90 vous avez beaucoup beaucoup changé et
vous êtes bonifié ah oui alors je devais
pas dire qu'ils s'étaient mais vous le
savez ce sera gilles verdez quoi
[Rires]
regarder cvrd combien d'enfants ont-ils
pu passer sous ce grillage procès
ferraille nous on a vu un casque jaune
et ça correspond à peu près à ce que
d'état d'employés à l'intérieur nous
disent c'est à dire que sous tous ces
amas de ferraille il ya des gants des
vêtements
je sais bien
et les mecs je leur envoie les vidéos
mettrait jeanne d'arc frères tox comment
isabelle à mais je trouve très très bien
c'est vrai ah oui vraiment c'est votre
style de mec lui
abbas était à cet âge là oui si vous
étiez avec une amoureuse à cette époque
toujours mais oui en allemand oui ah oui
merci
heureusement qu'on va s'appeler nathalie
je pense mais je pense je pense mais
j'ai un doute parce que j'ai un doute
sur l'année en fait c'est ça mon
problème un doute sur l'année dans
laquelle ça se passe je pense que c'est
aux 56 57
je pense qu'ils ont raison eh ben gilles
pour vous ce soir notre derrière j'ai
décidé de vous laisser un petit peu
reposé un gênant parce que vous avez
fait tellement de choses dans les prime
que c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui va
travailler tout de suite enora malagré à
enora malagré vous êtes petit mais vous
avez du talent si c'est la taille votre
taille
mais vraiment je ne corresponds pas
demain que vous n'êtes pas ne refaites
pas voilà près de nos talons vous avez
ramassé dans la nra vous nous avez
montré un jour que vous pouviez rentrer
dans une vallée absolument non mais
c'est vrai elles rentreront dans une
valise une petite vous pouvez donc
l'amener au voyage d'ailleurs elle vous
sera proposé en fin d'émission
je vous le dis est ce qu'on a les images
des nora qui rentre dans la valise et
juste après enora vous allez nous faire
un tour de magie avant d'accueillir bien
sûr matthieu delormeau avec son alter
ego 1
enora vous allez encore vous rapetisser
ccao dit comme ça c'est possible vous à
lui elle est petite et bien dans un
instant vous verrez barbie en vrai voilà
elle enlève le blouson et nora va
rentrer dans une valise et une oratrice
qui pouvait bien sûr et d'orages et
enora va partir dans un instant pour
madrid mais pas trop longtemps
attention attention ascension elle quand
même regarder et nora c'est bon on saute
dessus et doha si vous n'entendez dit je
vous entends je vous entends fait
remarquer qu'il est incapable de fermer
une valise ah si quand même non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
selon les sénateurs
m
alors
mais série s content d'atteindre cus
collinaires s'il vous plaît merci à
thurgovie ce que l'on fait l'émission
dans le noir merci bonjour comment vous
appelez libaert à nos jours ils
remercient de travail maïs c'est un
grand grand magicien il vous avez
préparé un truc extraordinaire et qu'il
aura le racontez vous ce qui va se
passer
ben on assiste et que et n'aura été
capable de se mettre dans une valise
oui c'est vrai donc on s'est dit que
finalement vous aviez peut-être envie de
la deûle à coincer oui là et de la fère
toupet de l'écraser un petit peu oui
c'est vrai qu'on a envie de l'écraser
bonjour monsieur
bravo pour le brushing merci beaucoup
vous êtes vous agrée anglais américains
français s'est quant au prénom
hervé hervé a tout simplement mais c'est
à vous d'avoir un look américain merci
énorme et cela parce que le mec en fait
plus ça va puis prend l'accent français
des bars et les banjos celles non c'est
à nos français je m'appelle hervé voile
ou faites moi j'étais juste à côté alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer
alors il aura voix je vous laisse faire
vous me dites et on va retrouver une
aura encore plus petit que ce canal et
on va la rendre leurs auteurs il n'y a
pas de petite musique magie un truc
hélas hélas ils me disent oui bien sûr
mais vous n'aimez pas la mettre à
l'égard alors enora jeu donc on va là on
va la retrouver très petites doses
qu'elle se place attention là on vous
voit m et là vous êtes super gronde mais
je suis là c'est ma taille normale
non c'est pas votre taille normale anti
chez les ch'ti c'est ma taille normale
attention je vous demander de tourner la
manivelle finalement parce que je pense
que tourner la manivelle de cargos
gisement alliés dans ce sens là vers le
bas vers le mardi ça tourne doucement
les y doucement à les y continuez
continuez un petit peu plus vite un
petit peu plus accéléré alors allez l
art alesi alesi alesi alesi allez-y
auparavant il aura est constitué allez-y
genesis and the ice et ce à deux tours
de magie n'est pas cela
extraits sinon ça arrivait donc aller
elle est comme ça les en cubes bondira
n'atterrit cube noir et sa règle
regardez ah oui je passe amène oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai et la haye mais c'est
fabuleux seriez quand vous sentez basque
quoi alors devoir m'absenter est ce
qu'elle se sent bien comme ça on va
retrouver de tagant baleineau elle n'est
pas retournée parti je tourne c'est
parti ça va ça va à laizy tranquille ah
oui voilà voilà
et bah merci
[Applaudissements]
et hop un peu dur et labrador
bravo enora fabuleux et merci merci
merci messieurs merci messieurs pour ce
tour j'avais des formidables merci
beaucoup merci les séries merci d'avoir
qu'elle aura ça ne rend pas et voilà
c'était c'est un petit cadeau que vous
voulez vous faire et vous isabelle dans
un instant vous allez danser le french
cancan ça ou pas mais pour le moment on
s'est dit ce qui a de plus beau dans
cette émission les plus beaux moments
d'amour ça reste quand même
isabelle morini bosc et ses anecdotes on
est quand même d'accord
isabelle vous avez vous avez des
anecdotes à chaque fois qu'est ce que
vous les inventer ce que sont toutes
vraies mais à priori oui d'accord j'ai
rien compris je regarde toujours en
cloque quel que soit le temps vous
dormez toujours en recul à vue l'accord
sur le canapé il est aux culottes sur le
canapé et une haute vienne ap au moins
quelques fois dans sa vie une femme
stimule parce que ça fait gagner
tellement longtemps poussé paul
pourcentage moins 80%
non vous faisait l'amour comme une fois
par semaine par exemple mois deux fois
par oui deux fois par semaine par ce
même col amélioré je bosse beaucoup donc
je me lève à 3h du matin
en semaine si l'on sait vendredi se
dresse au chat et le reste
thouars
viva
cissé il tape tout ça est vrai tout çà
et là c'est vous vous avez une vie est
exceptionnelle a vraiment isabelle à ce
que vous aimez dans cette émission
ce jeu où on fait le jeu avec la pomme
de terre
je n'ai pas d'actions et ben je vous
propose de regarder un petit extrait de
thalassa parce que c'était les quarante
ans que thalassa aujourd'hui et nous il
ya une image forte qu'on a gardé de
thalassa de ses 40 ans thalassa c'est
celle là lahlou est tombé en mer du
bateau qu'il a été récupéré par jean
louis c'est jamais facile
eric dumont lui a perdu eric dumont lui
à perrefitte samba pardon et il est en
train de rallier actuellement les
antilles c'est pas c'est pas facile et
c'est donc jean bourrel et fred dahirel
que l'on attend arnaud coyot rythme
alors tombé sur la plage aïn bernard
voulu emmener toujours sur la plage en
fait la mecque appétit oui c'est ça ou
jamais entendu j'avais bien repérer et
donc nous on s'était dit on voulait
rendre un hommage à thalassa que
thalassa chez la mère la mère c'est
l'amour on va pas faire non on va pas
faire une patate chaude veut pas non non
non on passe non qua non à ce quoi non
non ça appuie passe-passe le poulpe non
non
[Applaudissements]
mon corps
ça fait des malheureux station va jouer
au passe par le groupe avant d'avoir
matthieu delormeau juste avant parce que
vous vous n'avez pas de rendez-vous
après malheureusement mois ci moi aussi
j'ai rendez vous allez je vous donne des
gars attention alors on fera le passe
par le pool l'attention celui qui aura
le poulpe à la face des 100 minutes de
questions sans minutes ou un seconde
chance
merci merci à vous allez-y merci je
ferai pas tous âges et je vous serai
tout seul au bac un bon écoutez monsieur
n'a plus pour les autres de méchantes ed
alors qu'un alors regardez tient alors
la télé si quand même donné alors
attention
j'ai engagé des questions des mini jeux
vous posez donc des questions pendant
100 secondes les chéris celui qui aura
le poulpe au bout des seins seconde
devra faire quelque chose c'est se laver
les dents de manière très particulière
ces six dernières
avec nallet la demande l'acculent vous
avez vous passé ça pour l'instant
d'accord alors attention les chèques je
vous le dis celui qui aura le bouna à la
fin ici à la fin des 100 secondes devra
faire un dentifrice
c'est à dire qu'il se lavera les dents
avec du poisson d'accord si c'est pas du
tout aidé mais dans sa salle était tout
le temps s'il vous plaît secoué est-ce
que vous pouvez vous décalez s'il vous
plaît attention je vous posais des
questions des questions sur la
télévision bien sûr est-ce que vous êtes
prêts on va partir pour sa seconde et à
ce que matthieu delormeau et près
également fiction on peut faire remonter
le sol et sur gaza attention à ça sent
une odeur horrible aller à l'egypte elle
apprenait dans l'art à valérie bénaïm à
sa glee dans un instant
le perdant celui qui aura le poulpe dans
les mains fera un selphy sociaux top
quelle émission de télé a fait connaître
lors des chronos enlevez moi cette merde
et mettez dans le chrono souffle et
merci attention on est reparti top
quelle émission de télé a fait connaître
leur ordre et quoi oui on accroît
l'avancé si vous avez la bonne réponse
ou passé c'est au bout de bellegarde et
qui a écrit le livre très positif
l'amour dure trois ans gg pas s'alarmer
non vous garder un regard déterminé les
paroles de cette chanson je t'aime comme
un fou comme un soda communes seront les
stars de cinéma
oui quel est le nom français de la série
américaine the young and the restless le
jaune et le clochard les feux de l'amour
n'importe quoi vraiment fait un chinois
réussi à soulever 113 kg avec son pénis
exact ouais merci vraiment faux
jean-michel mais réussit à faire
construction avec son pénis photos
attention là bas à un jet
adaptation mais je suis à bulle époque
que veut que attention te veut tous les
jours la chanteuse lorie dans sa chanson
j'ai besoin d'amour
j'ai rien compris nicolin tous les jours
laurie dans sa chanson que j'ai besoin
de jours des bisous des bisous et quoi
des cannes des canards
alors vous avez soufflé un cabochon on
n'a pas droit de soufre par deux sinon
c'est plutôt dans la gueule attention
que quel animal mignon atteint la
première place du top 50 en 2010 un
panda mais non rené alors je sais ce que
vous allez faire top au bal au top on va
se retrouver dans un instant avec la
vous gardez le pouvais je le garde oh
[ __ ] mais ça vient
dans l'instant on va se retrouver avec
matthieu delormeau qui sera en battle de
danse avec notre ami et oui matthieu
delormeau sera aussi le perdant celui
qui aura le poulpe à la fin des trente
sept secondes fera un cellfish vous
allez voir vous allez vous brosser les
dents avec du poisson et c'est bon ça
contient du magnésium les cherry et
juste après il y à jean luc lemoine qui
arrivent pour les questions en 4/3 et on
aura du french croco et de la danse
acrobatique a tout de suite sur les huit
heures
l'envié bertrand a averti m merci à tous
on est en direct sur des 8es ya plein de
choses qui vont arriver dans un instant
on aura bien sûr jean luc lemoine qui va
venir pour les questions 4/3
exceptionnel il a des dossiers fou ça va
être les quatre tiers les plus longs
1depuis l'histoire des quatre terme ce
qui l'a beaucoup de choses à nous faire
faire je vous rappelle qu'on est à
l'antenne depuis en direct depuis je
vous le dis 4h06 et 36 secondes merci
d'être avec nous les séries on voulait
absolument être avec vous ce soir après
les éléments après les événements
tragiques bien sûr qu'ils sont passion
c'est bien il faut qu'on soit avec vous
ce vendredi une semaine après pendant
longtemps en direct et avec toute
l'équipe donc merci à tous d'être là
dans un instant il y aura également
bertrand chamerois oui à nous faire une
chronique sur quoi je pense que c'est
très il ya eu beaucoup d'amour depuis
c'est toutes ces saisons que tpm paix je
veux revenir sur les clash entre
chroniqueurs et je vais faire se
rabibocher les gens qui sont pas sans
cesse à ce que c'est que de l'amsa ça
c'est important aussi
valérie je crois que vous avez deux
surprises pour moi c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit je suis au courant du douce je me
suis occupé de votre cas moi c'est vrai
quand même quand vous dites surprises et
les surprises à la nounou des bonnes
surprises
je pense que ça devrait vous faire
plaisir série mercy qu'est ce qu'elle
est mignonne celle ci il ya mathieu
delormeau bien sûr qui arrivera dans un
instant en slip et qui va nous faire une
battle dance 1 avec d'autres amis je
vous le dis ils seront tous les deux
ensemble les deux à skis par mais pour
le moment nous sommes dans le poulpe le
poulpe c'est très simple ne pas se passe
par le pool oui je voulais juste faire
un petit bisou à tous les maliens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'embrasse notamment mon frère homo
comme m envoyer des textos ce cas
prennent vie et péter qui était vraiment
pas bien je n'embrasse jeu droite mokobé
également et tous les maliens alors
attention on va repartir on passe par le
poulpe je rappelle que celui qui aura le
poulpe à la fin des trente sept secondes
devra faire un
cellfish c'est à dire se brosser les
dents avec quatre ans avec du poisson
d'accord on y va vous êtes vous êtes ok
c'est bon ou la presse que je me
concentre sur ce que vous dites
alors attention quel animal mignon
atteint la première place du top 50 en
2010 à kuala non tenues et le maïs bt
d'éternuer
ok je le dis et non non mais enfin mais
le faire non les combats à lyon mais non
mais [ __ ] chacal millions mais la
question ne lui dit pas de lui dit pas
si vous avez tout intérêt à ce qu'ils
gardent le coup dit quoi quel animal
mignon atteint la première place du top
50 en 2010 allait mal mignon son top 50
non
[Applaudissements]
à
mais c'est pas possible je verrai ça ne
pouvait arriver qu'à lui il non mais
sans charrier mais c'est ma base et au
mécénat mais c'est lui mais tellement de
tout cas c'est sûr qu'il en est et je
vous jure il faut que je vous raconte
c'est magnifique a scoré dit la marque
de nourdine en fait on l'a pas parce que
l'ordinaire on l'a pas oula pas voilà
tout coule l'apa c'était rené la taupe
voilà bien sûr rené la taupe alors qu'on
amène s'il vous plaît tout ce qu'il faut
pour gilles verdez gilles vous allez
devoir alors je vous le dis ce que vous
allez devoir faire vous allez devoir
faire un don qui fiche fut peint
d'autriche
c'est très simple vous allez devoir vous
brosser les dents avec du poisson et
après vous choisirez ce sera pendant 5
secondes et après vous choisirez une
personne de votre choix ici auto la
table pour lui faire un gros bisou
parce que c'est la soirée de lamu un
bisou à quel endroit sur la bouche
ah oui bah oui oui je dirais la personne
de votre choix
je mets ça dans toutes les grosses juste
vous n'en prenez cuda cores ici une
grosse mare chicose alors certes ça dans
la résine alors on va montrer ses
légumes non mais elles sont déjà
utilisées c'est pas possible
nan alors allez-y
c'est beau s'annoncer
laissez-moi la meinau le film est pas dû
avaler [ __ ] mais crash
alors à gazon gilot qui choisissez vous
faut faire un gros bisou mon nouvel ami
jean-michel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi tous les deux ans et vous
pensez les dents
[Applaudissements]
allez allez vous procéder dans les
séries avant d'avoir bertrand chamerois
je propose qu'on se détendent un peu
eh oui matthieu delormeau matthieu
delormeau et près matthieu delormeau va
nous faire ça danse avec notre ami crazy
j'appelle crée ainsi un bien sûr ils
sont là tous les deux en slip une battle
de danse tous les deux en slip sur la de
leurs modèles
bien sûr ça fait longtemps qu'on attend
ça et juste après bertrand chamerois ce
sera à vous et après bien sûr on aura
une surprise de valérie bénaïm et après
juste jean luc lemoine qui est arrivé ça
y est il viendra nous rejoindre dans un
instant pour les questions en 4/3 c'est
parti matthieu delormeau et critique
[Applaudissements]
les loups
[Musique]
la danse
mettez vous bien
j'ai vu bien là oh là là les deux
allaient attaquer martine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remporté leurs 2
les deux installés dans le temps riz
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regrets
de baisse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mondiale
la petite jeune rapide gens parce que
les bacs jaunes et les filles quand même
c'est un match normal
rabat avec ça c'est pas bien votre
prénom c'est ça pendant que vous
appliquerez belge erwin staudt merci et
merci continue à me battre et c'est
comme ça en ville est magnifique je dois
dire bravo un max de larmes aux bastons
oleme très bon enfant et exceptionnel
vraiment marché vous êtes une bande à
bord vraiment vous êtes un livre qui
donne et des excédents assez gentil
merci j'avais vraiment à ce que vous
avez fait là mais vous quand vous mettez
un match où vous transforme message que
je n'allais pas bien
non mais ça n'est plus le même homme le
gars ont été très demandées sidibé
vraiment je ferai pas une soirée masquée
avec vous dieu dira compagnies grognent
jamais faire de balle basque adegi le
très très mal tourner il attend bien sûr
aller robert cramer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir c'est que l'amour des mecs on a
un mec qui est pas bien du tout c'est
gilbert des ça ça va très bien ça
remonte un peu dans les remugles si vous
devez vous bien sûr je suis tout de
suite
non pas du tout il ya des amis à côté
qui peut il ya des amis qui ont des
mains les amis c'est fait pour ça ce
soir c'est que l'amour je vais donc
revenir sur tous les moments d'amour
qu'on a connu dans cette émission grâce
aux copains autour de la table c'est
donc tout naturellement qu'il y aura
beaucoup de gilles verdez également du
gilles verdez est un peu de gilles
verdez et beaucoup de mathieu parce
qu'on va revoir les images de son
arrivée dans tpm paix qui était vraiment
plein d'amour et cette année pour
commencer avec gilles c'est un gilles
différent plus détendu calme et apaisée
que les autres années qu'on a découvert
non je déconne je sers attention au
casting c'est à dire que les gens qui
vont intervenir faudra pas qu'ils
deviennent eux-mêmes des personnages
qu'ils soient des caricatures faut
qu'ils aient délaissé les français trop
ce qu'ils sont vous les côtoyer
[Applaudissements]
je vais des jours nous éructer contre
moi comme un roquet affamés cessé de
crier thierry moreau repreneur
[Musique]
j'aimerais quand même que ce soir on est
une grosse pensée pour celles qui se
retrouvent le plus souvent ainsi sauf ce
soir à côté de gilles abassi encore ce
soir
isabeau si nous nous avons tout fait le
tracé isabelle sa cellule mais je les
confonds toujours là il est plein extra
man isabelle qui a perdu tout sens de
l'audition du côté gauche il est
totalement responsable voulait exonérer
de tout mais non ça va me aba s'il n'a
pas choisi sa bande si la paix choisi
noël si la paix qu'est ce que tu as toi
mais laisse moi parler il ya deux ans
l'arrivée jean dans l'équipe a perturbé
jean-michel j'ai vu que tu t'en lui un
concurrent redoutable en gentleman
capable comme lui de faire tomber toutes
les femmes dans ses filets avec ses
belles paroles amis poètes bonsoir je
voulais juste dire à gilles qui devrait
un peu plus nick et pour les vacances
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous avez dit il est un
peu plus ludique et pour les vacances il
était très tendu ça m'énerve là si je
peux me permettre c'est le camembert qui
se moque du roquefort et père de
nicotine toi et moi je me mets moi je me
disperse pas et victor hugo balzac et
sentex nous on à gilles verdez niveau
citation fera jamais mieux que sa
jumelle
donc le problème de gilles à l'ordre un
des problèmes fondamentaux c'est qu'en
fait il est véritablement coincé du cul
des quais des missions pour prendre un
peu de séduction d'amour y un peu de
sexe ait tout de suite il ce drame dont
est extrait l'amour un peu et mes moyens
cher jr il est bien chez avant le coeur
très très tendre et la tob très très dur
le coeur le coeur tendre et les le coeur
tendre et laptop dû ressentir de
l'accord à toi mais pourquoi tu as fait
le choix inverse alors dit explique nous
à ce point mathieu puisque l'année
dernière nous recevions ici mathieu qui
venaient nous parler de son recueil de
poésie ou d'un nouveau numéro spécial de
tellement vrai je ne sais plus trop et
c'est ce soir là que ses yeux bleus jean
vanoye alors va t elle passer comme ça
mais elle est passée vite mais elle a le
mérite d'avoir existé
c'est ce soir là que c'est yeux bleus
ont croisé le chemin du regard amoureux
de gilles verdez instant choupi love
vous avez une responsabilité c'est de
rendre un culte nos ados qui vont
préférer vos doubles à la lecture et à
des choses plus intelligentes si l'avion
ça je vous trouve n'est pas parce que l
évasion
est-ce que vous avez mal à votre
jeunesse
quand je vois ce que monsieur présente
j'ai mal à mes ados j'ai mal à ma
jeunesse à oui c'est vrai cette
rencontre pleine de douceur gilles sous
le charme n'attendait qu'une chose
retrouver son âme soeur matt on avait
des choses à se dire
il est venu ici on discute le petit
bichon je le prends même sur mes genoux
lors d'un quiz oui c'est une soirée
riche c'était réglé et continua
m'allumer à me chercher sur twitter il a
dit que j'étais un personnage nauséabond
alors moi je veux dire matthieu
delormeau pour une fois soit un homme si
tu as quelque chose à me dire tu viens
là et tu me trouveras
fin août la nouvelle est tombée matthieu
delormeau rejoint notre équipe bilan 4
malaise dans l'équipe et le jour de son
arrivée mathieu espérer un pot d'accueil
sympa et chaleureux
vous êtes heureux avec nous maintenant
oui lada mal pour un bien je pense comme
ça on à percer l'abcès revoilà cette
fenêtre mal à se dire et de plus bas
parce que le raid à moi quand on perd ce
lapse et il reste plus qu'à mettre un
bon pansements bon c'est moi c'est beau
abu salim jay ça y est voilà mmo merci
maintenant rien
il a la gueule
cannes vous savez
j'aurai je reste quand même sont pas
trop hein c'est vrai mais vous avez
parfois entre patrons et employés non a
pas de tout récemment pas touche la
moselle jean jacques rey merci qui a dit
ça no zob in job n'est pas sur le tour
du qatar
le convoi du coup les images de
l'arrivée de mathieu plutôt qu'un peu
d'arrivées sympa on a préféré débattre
sur sont arrivés bonne ou mauvaise idée
y'a pas à dire on sait bien les
accueillir les nouveaux alors mathieu
donc mathieu est ce que c'est une bonne
ou une mauvaise idée dans touche pas à
mon poste c'est à cet instant que
mathieu a compris que son année serait
longue et douloureuse
en moins de dix minutes l'équipe est
parvenue à lui faire regretter les
gloussements des anges d'nrj 12 mai est
mature n'a pas ces mauvaises années
ensemble soit a été quelqu'un de sympa
avec moi c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas été
top pouvoir il le sait très bien il n'a
pas été cool très mauvaise idée c'est
une sorte de sous l'habile a donc il a
été comme étant deux sous l'habile ah
ouais il va être extrêmement langue de
bois
c'est un mauvais débatteurs j'y crois
pas une seconde ça fait sept ans qui me
vont même plus de sept ans que tu me
vends des programmes de merde qui me
pourrissent la vie je veux dire donc me
retrouver avec lui là franchement
excusez moi mais ça me laisse un bien
beau jour de rentrée pour matthieu
delormeau beau match et c'est fini tout
ça c'est du passé il sait pas cher c'est
quoi c'est la couleur que j'avais quand
j'étais très jeune chemise et répondeur
aller et c'est pas parce que vous avez
changé de couleur je vous dis non mais
comme ça le débat est clos
je vous aime beaucoup mais ça restera
toujours de l'amitié série que je vaux
je prenais beaucoup de sujets a quand
même parce que 1 commence à m'angoisser
vous le dit voilà je vous préfère vous
dire les choix c'est beau à regarder
mais quelqu'un dans le public qui vient
de cracher jouer juste pour finir il
faudrait que quand même que gill était
le plus virulent dans le magnéto à
propos de l'arrivée de mathieu donc vous
allez vous rabibocher ce soir g45 plus
cartes avec des trucs sympas parce que
c'est que d'amour ce soir tu vas en
choisir une et tu vas devoir exécuter le
gage qui est sur cette carte avec
mathieu non non parce qu'un seul à
passer la lettone ça va vous magouiller
pavois non halal à on peut pas faire ça
non non voyez vous voulez pas ça vous
[Applaudissements]
au revoir merci master class et aurait
averti les versets je veux dire mon rêve
ouais j'ai très envie parce qu'ils ne
demandent jamais j'ai très envie qui
m'apprennent la douleur modène c'est de
le faire une fois c'est vrai mais super
plaisir vous fait la semaine prochaine à
faire tu veux bien saisir mais elle sera
débattue touche c'est après de sérieux
dans un instant les chéris ya jean luc
lemoine qui va venir nous rejoindre pour
les questions en 4/3 et il ya du très
très très très très très lourd je vous
le dis pour le moment valérie bénaïm je
sais que vous avez une surprise alors on
m'a dit qu'il y avait une surprise pour
moi qui a été dans le public c'est ça
l'histoire alors déjà il ya thierry
moreau qosi qui va arriver dans cette
matière est déjà dans le public on
avance et moi ma surprise à l'est où le
public ya une surprise alors qu'est ce
que c'est je vais pas vous dire c'est
surprise cyril pas baissé quelques
secondes mais alors c'est à dire que
nous aussi on en vous avez voulu me
faire un cadeau puis vous vous appelez
notre entourage vous appeler pour savoir
s'il ya des choses qu'on fait ou des
gens qu'on aime ou qu'on n'a pas revus
depuis longtemps nous aussi on appeler
votre entourage
airtran delta et bavard cyril oui votre
entourage a parlé et donc il ya
quelqu'un quelque part dans le public il
ya quelqu'un à qui vous devez beaucoup
si c'est vrai c'est je dirais presque
que c'est quelqu'un qui vous a façonné
et de vous l'homme que vous êtes
aujourd'hui on perd c'est pas votre père
mère pas votre maman enlever la famille
fiori c'est quelqu'un de très très
important c'est plutôt de ce côté ci si
je peux me permettre d'aller plus vite
quand même d'accord la lie sur xavier
local canada non pas parce que je
cherche on va me thierry moreau parce
qu'il paraît qu'il est dans le public
aussi
mais c'est lui c'est moctar non quoi y'a
quelqu'un que j'ai pas vu depuis
longtemps que je dois reconnaître
normalement même osé poser des questions
peut-être mon coach freddy quelqu'un de
la famille quincaille non c'est pas de
la famille c'est quelqu'un qui a compté
cyril qui l'a pas vu depuis longtemps
ouais depuis vingt ans les marais où il
peut avoir changé quoi c'est mon prof de
tennis et votre prof de tennis
vous avez trouvé votre prof de tennis là
jean-marie vite et pas de m'arriver
c'est énorme
jean-marie viney thomas thuram ont
démarré
énorme et ça fait grenoble ce n'est pas
du 22 au 23
il est beau gosse ou parent prof de
tennis sans rigoler oui je sais pas ça
vous dire mais moi je trouve en pleine
forme aurait touché et c'est toujours un
petit peu et arrêter combien de temps je
suis 15 à 15 heures oui jean marine
quand on a parlé alors venez
asseyez-vous quoi il n'y avait pas dit a
pas de dossier sur moi j'espère que
quand on a parlé avec jean marie et nous
a dit beaucoup de choses à votre égard
il vous aime beaucoup
non mais je les adore s'il aime beaucoup
vous aviez quoi 15 ans peu près bien sûr
c'est un quinze ans vous étiez déjà
quelqu'un de droit c'est vrai
franchement vous c'est vrai que j'en ai
tout moment on aurait pu qualifier cyril
quand il était c'était j'ai eu toute la
période entre 15 et 17 ans la bonne paye
la meilleure période chez les garçons à
serrer la vis aux fêtes
il s'entraînait c'était quelqu'un qui
s'entraîner sérieusement ça a été un
honnête joueur je crois qu'il a été 15,3
au tennis mais nous on en a entraîné ces
joueurs là toute l'année parce que l'été
on partait à la baule avec eux on en a
emmené une vingtaine et là on partait
faire des compétitions
ah ouais je me suis battu à la boule
d'or africain avec au ping pong c'est
vrai donc nous partions à la baule
avec ces joueurs-là motivés prêts à
faire plein de performance cyril était
très brillant avec deux copains à lui
avec jonathan et et olivier audouze
aussi il est il faisait plein de
performance mais auprès des filles
surtout un point de vue tennis il
essayait de s'en sortir mais par contre
ils essayent de faire vraiment le grand
chelem avec leurs copains
[Rires]
c'était c'était une période très sympa
c'est 1 minute et un peu branleur quand
même à l inverse susan rice et pis s'il
faut pas me voir jean deroyer ce que
séka séka grâce à l'amour de l'être et
ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils sont vraiment
mon chéri vraiment hâte j'ai une petite
anecdote aussi à maire de novara et là
tu vas dire des conneries oui vas-y mon
endroit où on était hébergé je me
souviens qu'une nuit avait quitté il
devait avoir 16 ans 17 ans il avait
quitté le lieu d'hébergement ils étaient
allés à la plage boire des bières on
avait du mal à les récupérer quand même
chaud merci pour toute l'admiration que
j'ai pour toi et bata un amour vous
embarquent jambes arriver là une autre
surprise continue puisque il ya thirion
qui a été complètement relooké avant
d'accueillir jean luc lemoine inquiet
près il y a donc thierry moreau qui a
été complètement relooké et et je vous
le dis
mais n'ont jamais regardé tout révéler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même aux exceptionnelles par yun et yang
c'est énorme c'est à dire mais je le
reconnais pas du tout ils m'ont goisses
à la basse et mais s'écoulant comme ça
franchement dites nous ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous préférez terry mots
comme ça ou comme ça thierry je m'en
sors à la baule vous êtes dégueulasse or
depuis les villes émission comment est
ce que vous préférez avant ou maintenant
là quand même
et ça c'est très bizarre j'ai peur ouais
c'est par bossi et les cas j'aime assez
rock ses matches à temps pour être
honnête dans les deux cas crystal là là
là comme ça définitivement il était
dégueulasse avant mais moins que là
quand même
isabelle non non je suis un village
agréable dans les deux cas mais voilà
une soirée seulement
ah oui fait peur et il est rempli mignon
vraiment bertrand en vrai les plus beaux
tirez vous sentez comment comme ça dans
le micro d'un micro tout va bien c'est
les lentilles sont plus gênant paix
sinon c'est à vous les enlevez montré
étonnant non non saisie c'est très très
étonnant ça y est cegid a fait un
travail incroyable richesse
ça fait un peu serial killer non mais
franchement vous ne faites que la peur
comme ça je vous dis merci mais vous
discuterez après allez on n'a qu'un coup
tu dois lui que brad a laissé partir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le terrain
ça va remonter en rupture et mon bébé il
est très beau ça va ce qu'il est bon si
baudouin chapeau melon et bottes de cuir
et ses bas de ma chaise ça marchera pas
les questions en 4/3 de jean luc lemoine
et oui si vous nous rejoignez si vous ne
connaissez pas l'émission jean luc
s'intéresse à tout ce qui se passe en
off c'est à dire ce qu'on voit pendant
les pubs ce qu'on voit pas même pendant
les émissions et jean-luc décrypte tout
ça et aujourd'hui il m'a dit tout à
l'heure à la radio cyril j'ai dû très
très très très lourd c'est ça exactement
alors grâce à vous bah quoi est ce que
c'est une question n'ont pas beaucoup de
moi mais regardez vous allez voir j'en
ai marre allez c'est parti
bonjour je m'appelle daniel cyril
hanouna dit souvent que vous êtes ami
depuis plus de 15 ans donc je voulais
savoir est ce que c'est un bon ami ou
une petite crevure comme tous les gens
du showbiz que j'ai d'abord fait que des
amis
donc j'avais 4 ans croise fait péter un
peu le concept alors c'est pas bon tu
sais pas si je suis désolé mais c'est
une excellente question que vous posez
la chaire daniel oui syrie est un homme
bien puisque je vous le rappelle il a
recruté la majeure partie de ses
chroniqueurs à pôle emploi
après est-ce que c'est un bon ami jeudi
longtemps cru mais maintenant je peux
admirer non comme dirait ma fille de 5
ans et un gros caca les messieurs
horrible non c'est vous le savez
peut-être je fais un spectacle depuis
janvier 2015
et depuis la première si rim annonce sa
venue chaque semaine pour finalement me
dire qui viendra la semaine suivante je
suis en tenez pas rigueur je veux aussi
qu'ils étaient débordés qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de responsabilités je serait
plaint d' excuses et un jour et
ingénieurs janvier la wii tétouan est ce
qu'un jour ma je suis tombé sur ça
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
on adore souple et moi j'allais voir le
spectacle fut génial le spectale
document un tipi
ok donc je résume un ami de vingt ans on
va pas le voir mais un petit pingouin
qui est sorti sans qu on se précipite
j'ai pas honte de le dire ça m'a fait
mal mais j'étais prêt à pardonner
j'étais prêt à pardonner et puis c'est
passé ça non elle entre autres aux ailes
à très content ce soir avec nous et on
retrouve aux folies bergères suis allé
voir le spectacle daly city
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis désolé quand tu passes
après alan est un pingouin tu que ton
amitié c'est de la merde
ce soir j'ai plus aucun ami dans
l'équipe mais j'allais vous êtes mon ami
non c'est fini c'est fini je passe pas
après un hanoïen paraguay vraiment déçus
qui pendant des années et fait en sorte
de montrer le meilleur de syrie est
comme quand il mettait l'eau à la bouche
au moment des coming next
ah oui et on va se retrouver dans un
instant aux émissions de fou gad elmaleh
quebrada
voilà gad elmaleh cela dit si bien le
vendre leur âme sais c'est que ce soir
là les autres chroniqueurs était de dos
et vous savez pourquoi
et bien parce que cyril avait eu une
idée de happening juste avant la prise
d'antenne ah oui allez-y je vous
retourne et je vous met un doigt dans le
cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sympa et sinon il est sympa trop trop il
a une facilité que peu de gens ont il
peut passer d'un sujet à l'autre en un
instant la regarder il était agacé par
quelqu'un et d'un seul coup sûr gavras
va croiser le regard d'une des nouvelles
de la saison mondiale auraint rouges sur
les fusils retour et en hiver les choses
aucun nom
quand tu rends dans l'équipe cherry te
montre son zizi
si tu lui dis qu'il est beau battue
reste dans l'équipe c'est bizarre cette
obsession
en tout cas ça me fait une magnifique
transition pour parler de jean michel mr
qu'avec une fois n'est pas coutume je
voudrais rendre hommage à mon camarade
qui ne dis pas que des grossièretés
attendant l'émission il fait d'autres
choses
messieurs dames contrairement aux idées
reçues et jean michel maire n'a pas que
des tops à la bouche
non il nous sort parfois aussi des deux
mauvais pas la signer ses taux dès dudit
sûr favorable de bébert chamerois essai
qui est un renard c'est à grenoble de
baseball rénovation d'accord le mec a
fait ce sweat il est quand même attaqué
pourquoi l'ong heil a mis une tête de
renard une batte de base ball l'équipe
américaine de baseball est plus connue
s'appelle et fox je pense à un rapport
avec ça franchement vous ça fait du bien
d'avoir quelqu'un qui a du bagout comme
ça qu'elle d'expérience jusque là tout
va bien puisque je peux la triomphe
modeste et il a raison d'être modeste
car après vérification il ya les white
sox de chicago
1 on vous regarde le logo les red sox de
boston
ah oui hein mais en fait c'est pas des
renards c'est des chaussettes
alors pour des crétins comme nous qui
est que des soirées au baseball ça passe
le problème c'est quand vous avez un
nord américain comme gilbert rozon sur
le plateau lui tic un tout petit peu
plus ça se passait fussent après le
triomphe modeste de jean michel maire je
sais ce que je peux
elle peter velits pour le déstabiliser
c'est compliqué en même temps c'est
normal qu'ils connaissent pas tous les
équipes de baseball parce que sa
spécialité c'est quoi ces les médias
c'est vrai il connaît tout le monde doit
donner la réponse vous êtes méchant
parce que c'était sa profession c'est
quoi la base journalistes journalistes
médias aussi bien sûr voilà est bien la
preuve c'est très impressionnant
je trouve que ces gens ces gens à mito
qui non mais
ça s'appelle le conquis par mam a pas le
compte était bon sur la france a un
incroyable talent aux roses ont sapé le
but du jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je prépare des trucs se fait peur
confessionnelle
c'est un professionnel bonjour
spécialistes on a aussi isabelle morini
bosc qui elle a une autre particularité
elle est polyglotte la mecque les mots
ya ça mais ça veut dire baisser les bras
et ont joué en brasse mois
[Rires]
ps - ce qui m'oblige à reparler de jean
michel maire
la transition est obligée après le
baseball laisse-moi caravane nous avons
parlé de ton dans ce chan o cha la
deuxième sur cette voie là on va parler
de la lourdeur du mois à recevez vita et
regardez ce clip
enfin nous ont regardés son clip
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et moi j'adore la musique de butare et
elle est très très très jolie n'empêche
pas très joli thierry manquaient pas
mais quand on voit sa gueule on comprend
qu'il aime pas mais il a changé là quand
même
il fait peur j'ai changé on dirait la
prof notre prof de d'éducation manuelle
et technique ouais c'est ça monsieur
shukar alors jugé lundi dans cette
rubrique un petit conseil deux invités
féminine quand vous rentrez sur le
plateau surtout ne touchez pas
jean-michel n'arrive pas à gérer
c'était priscilla
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
bien sûr
karajan
quel regard ma position
pas possible ringard pareil mais le clin
d'oeil à l'ancien il peut pas s'en
empêcher c'est pour ça qu'en septembre
on a un peu craint pour la sécurité
d'erika moulet art il a rejoint cette
année et comme elle a oublié d'être
vilaine et bien évidemment ça ça crée
des convoitises d'après vous qui s'est
précipité le premier jean michel et ben
non non et ben non
ah les jours à la grande surprise de
tirs est mort au regard des noms
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eric à l'arrêt c'est vrai qu'elle est ma
langue a fourché
c'est bon ça va saigner vous c'est votre
s'il veut y aller car trop facile non
mais trop facile
non mais c'est donc c'est votre style ou
pas jusqu'à présent je trouve plutôt
sympathiques comme garçons vous pourriez
sortie avec lui bah non non non non non
mal à terminer définitivement terminée
se souvient qu'avant c'était vous étiez
pas si mal au départ voilà il n'était
pas si mal ça vaut mieux pas et eric f
et l'uruguay elle parle dans sa base
aujourd'hui pour jean-michel trop facile
jean-michel il aime gagner du challenge
le problème c'est qu'à force de dire à
thierry que c'était facile avec erika
bareigts fihri s'est un peu emballé
c'est l'image la plus gênante du mois eh
bien on n'a jamais vu tirer comme ça
c'est magnifique
bienvenue à ya qu la pipe au moment des
cubes
[Applaudissements]
c'est vite à autre chose à ce que là il
est pas bien joué bon au moins il a
essayé
passons aucun mathieu de lambeaux salut
je fais savoir je suis rentré j'étais en
slip c'est normal tout à fait normal ces
démissions d'embâcles a pris une bonne
place dans l'émission quand même les
foulées saint matthieu delormeau a une
tête à celle fille c'est à dire que quel
que soit son attitude de départ des
canes appareil apparaît et change de
tête poussent des yeux et fait un
sourire ni est figé entre la statue de
cire et est un enfant du village des
damnés
regardez la transformation en temps réel
ouattara
c'est basique
ce mac est formidable et toujours la
même pause et vous pouvez vérifier un
peu importe la personne à côté il fait
la même tête regarder avec vincent
duclos à jeff pas des cloques être
maître gims shy'm benji non et même
rihanna
de malibu
j'étais fort heureusement que vous êtes
arrivés très récemment
ça c'est des belles recrues times alpiq
a lancé ariane à vous rappeler incité
lors de la fameuse émission battue avait
été hypnotisé qu il comptait quitter à
côté de rihanna il nous avait tous
beaucoup fait rire ce que vous n'avez
pas vu par contre c'est qu'à un moment
mathieu a vu une jolie rouge sur le
plateau est donc logiquement il s'est
dit que en plus de rihanna il avait
aussi invité à dell la chanteuse 1
et comme sa passion c'est les stéroïdes
et laissez-les fille il n'a pas pu s'en
empêcher
regardez bien la joie dans son regard à
la fin le mec depuis qui la touche pas à
mon poste il rend compte que des stars
[Applaudissements]
leur prochain le roi aussi été petit
c'est ce choix ouais lui qui croyait que
tout le monde était nu sur le plateau le
problème c'est que dans sa tête il
voyait vraiment tout jusqu'au moindre
détail et grâce à lui on a su qu'il y
avait un chanteur célèbre dans le public
en mai faisait en direct les jeunes gens
fument tête c'est un chanteur qui avait
fait ça pour les jeunes regardez quand
on sait que c'est le cerveau de bertrand
qui associée cette image
madame je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
dans sa tête la pauvre dame
et bien cette dame
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la stib à ça vous va très bien c'est
vraiment hors du cac la meilleure place
de la soirée ce soir là cet essai de
valérie bénaïm qui a passé sa soirée
essayé de rassurer bertrand et de
s'intéresser à lui
quoi qu'ils disent là il va bloquer sur
notre écran géant high heel valérie va
dire n'importe quoi et surtout bertrand
qu'asseoir et beaucoup de cars et dans
l'est dans le grand carré où il ya
beaucoup de cars et ouais ouais ya
beaucoup de cas il ya beaucoup de carrés
dans le grand quart mais de rejet
maintenant mêmes sources et de belle
manière ses bombes mais l'animal a
réponse à tout
[Musique]
il n'est surtout pas le contrarier quand
ils sont sous hypnose faut pas les
contrats mais là on entre la compassion
et le foutage de gueule ça lui aurait
dit je suis anna dont elle leur a dit si
bien tu parles paient des impôts total n
importe quoi enfin bon en bref
maintenant là
la reine du vent 7 ce mois-ci c'est
hydra et nora qui a d'abord voulu parler
à matthieu delormeau problème il était
parti aux toilettes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ça c'est gentil la suite est plus
compliqué il n'aura va essayer de parler
aux rédacteurs en chef adjoints roma en
gros un grand succès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a bologhine
la peau
salah salah radical voilà en tout cas si
vous nous rejoignez merci d'être avec
nous on en dirait kcc jean-luc le boisé
il sait pas où le majestic du mois c'est
gilles verdez non mais admirez vit
vraiment l' esquive d'isabelle
morini-bosc j'ai réfléchi au début de la
séquence pour vous prouver qu'elle était
concentré sur la performance
[Musique]
c
plus
j'ai voulu
[Rires]
non non mais là là là vous faites exprès
arrêtez vous faites exprès vous avez
très bien entendu avec le recul je ne
sais plus moi je devrais pas être
méchant mais pas d'excès vexé ah ben oui
sans doute d'accord merci
mais là ils étaient 23 dans 37 est elle
déjà elle est déjà on a perdu là bas
j'ai quelque chose pour elles à la fin
quelque chose c'est que vous allez voir
que là il faudrait pas la garder trop
longtemps après plus de deux mois de
présence dans notre équipe matthieu
delormeau poursuit son bizutage et s'est
assis sans le faire exprès sur l'homme
invisible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non je plaisante je plaisante mathieu
battu avait en fait malencontreusement
ranger son téléphone portable dans ce
slip et il a reçu un appel non on dans
les pubs les chroniqueurs s'ennuie donc
on leur donne des ardoises pour qu'il
puisse dessiner un cd duo comme exercice
mais ça en dit long sur la personnalité
de chacun regardez j'ai dessiné que
l'isie a pas mis là c'est quoi
elles descendent des affaires cebr non
elle dit de toi pas dû lui coûter mais
non il veut démontrer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pourtant dans l'équipe tout le monde
le sait mathieu est très amoureux d'un
garçon l'équipe de mathieu oui j'en ai
vu des mecs qui ce qui fait mais leur
fille mais c'est un poème
là il va rejoindre cyril au poste de
présentateur et par mégarde il va faire
la boulette il va se regarder dans
l'écran de retour et en se voyant
mathieu avoir une révélation
il n'a jamais rien vu d'aussi beau le
mec va littéralement bloqué avant de se
reprendre
regardez ouais mais tu veux pas réagir
sur le raid accord est à des beautés
tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez vous à quoi bon retour à dieu
non pas tant de faire chier s'il y avait
une chose non sur laquelle il faut pas
plaisanter avec mathieu c'est le
physique là dessus mais les ultras
premier degré donc souvent il oublie
qu'il est en émission il fait des
commentaires comme madame michu devant
sa télé et en ce moment j'ai besoin de
perdre du poids je suis à deux kilos de
mon poids de forme
70 818 beaucoup hein
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça se travaille à paris les invités du
moins ce sont les comédiens de scènes de
ménages
scènes de ménages qui ont apprécié leur
venue chez nous regardez juste la
différence entre ce qu'ils disent et
comment ils vont s'aimer julien courbet
juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors mes choix du tout par l'est et par
an rien rien ces incapables de dire un
mot
quelqu'un je vous assure c'est une cata
3 l et les pauvres ils étaient bloqués
bah ouais voilà l'esprit c'était pas par
rapport à julien je pense à leur
apparition c'est marrant de dire ça
c'est le cas c'est bon les reins
quittera indiqueront d'ailleurs il est à
moi le français en promettant d'utiliser
les stocks peux vous dire que j'ai vu
comment ils ont changé comme l approche
de julien parce qu'il faut le sas et
c'est très compliqué de faire semblant
d'être content en télé il faut des
années pratique par exemple mathieu
delormeau
la syrie va le dire un mot gentil qui va
beaucoup déstabilisé
regardez bien sa tête le mec est pas
bien et regarder ensuite sa maîtrise au
moment de reprendre l'antenne
tu fermes ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
le renouveau le numéro 1 le champion du
monde
voilà c'est juste n'importe quoi parce
qu'on a le décompte 1 on est en direct
un dans touche pas au poste depuis 4
heures 52 minutes et car j'espère
j'espère sincèrement que vous ne voyez
pas le temps pas si on voulait
absolument faire cette émission avec
vous ce soir
cette émission direct être a des goûts
je sais qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont
restés à la maison et j'espère vous
passer un bon moment avec n'oubliez pas
toujours un le hastag c'est que de la
journée celle où des petits mots ou à
des gens que vous aimez ça nous fera
extrêmement plaisir et ça leur fera
plaisir
alors moi j'ai envie que vous êtes très
élégant merci très très déçu comme en
seconde période trop trop trop trop ça
revient ça revient vous en faites pas on
est sous tension est encore moi je suis
tranquille je suis passé non vous
revenez tout de suite
voilà lors du dernier prime était très
inquiet à l'idée qu'on puisse détruire
sa voiture a heureusement non savoir ce
que sont michel jean michel va essayer
de le rassurer
à sa façon tout en classe et en
distinction
tu l'écrasera
il a deja qu il est à l arrêt des
actions plateau jeudi soir double assure
me taper prend six mois
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est que de l'amour en bien sûr ce soir
et j'espère vraiment que tout le monde
nous regarde
sauf cette personne voilà à s'échouer
c'est chaud oui c'est vrai mais c'est
jean luc lemoine et jean luc lemoine a
le droit de tout faire il a le totem
d'immunité voile était vrai il s'est
même battu n'était pas bien mais mes
séries il est comme ça il aime jouer
avec ses chroniqueurs et les maîtres
comme il le dit lui-même dans son
langage fleuri embrassera en angoisse
est donc pour rendre hommage à la syrie
les son oeuvre
je lance une nouvelle rubrique le à deux
trois grades de trois rats sera quoi ces
lois de croire à la diva j'adore
hu
[Musique]
il est vrai qu'il est à côté des
gagnants medica spas pour une séquence
était kraft aqesss
[Applaudissements]
et moi je me suis pas là
on est lundi on est lundi
tu viens me déguiser la dégommer l'autre
imagine vendredi te coupe une jambe a
pas de séquences moi j'ai d'écouler un
point j'ai roulé une pelle et morini
bosc
il m'a écrasé ma caisse
son tour
excellent là ça on est bien
je sais que certains ont été choqués par
la séquence de tir à l'arc
évidemment on ne le fait pas chez vous
non le fait que si vous avez jean michel
meyer apporter de l'eau et ils sachent
et là je veux pas être trop mais cyril
était très mal après cette séquence
alors la seule que je vais montrer et
pas spécialement drôle mais l'important
pour que vous compreniez que chez cyril
derrière le masque du clown ya aussi un
homme là après avoir blessé son ami s'il
va se laisser submerger par l'émotion et
ça va s'effondrer littéralement des
images poignantes
[Rires]
d'ailleurs
therrien patois sais rien depuis vous
n'avez plus rien vous étiez volontaire
c'est tout à votre soigner le lemay qui
tirait flèche dans la tête de son
chroniqueur et après ils engagent les
jours une des grandes nouveautés de
touche pas en poste cette année c'est le
passage de l'émission en direct le
vendredi
ah oui julien combe elle annoncé lors
d'une émission on va faire un petit jeu
deviner quel est le chroniqueur qui
n'est pas emballé par cette idée
un indice il est habillé en rouge et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que la semaine
d'après donc dans quinze jours on
débarque en direct tous les revendeurs
[Applaudissements]
oui
où es tu
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pas à voir la vidéo et je suis
tout seul alors il n'a pas l'air
convaincu mais il savait mais il faut la
comprendre
entre ses émissions de radio pas un peu
ces compétitions de badminton et ses
rapports conjugaux le week-end
elle est au bout du rouleau mais
franchement quels sont au bout du
rouleau ça se voit à peine
[Musique]
bien entendu on est amis dès cette
semaine nous inquiète
ainsi on est d'abord raté je vous
accueille et vous accueille
parce que dans la catégorie chanteur de
l'année et c'est pas une vanne est aussi
ce type normal
[Musique]
là on va se faire
france 3 juillet je n'ai pas réussi à
les pratiquer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez allez comprendre égal avec vous
bonjour je m'appelle and la semaine
dernière lors d'une émission j'ai trouvé
tous vos chroniqueurs intelligent donc
je voulais savoir était telle douche
sous hypnose
[Applaudissements]
une dernière chose
j'avais prévu et j'avais promis un
cadeau au public mais pour faire gagner
ce cadeau au public
je vais devoir c'est aussi un cadeau aux
cigarettes que je me suis fais moi ce
que je sais faire le mieux c'est quoi
ces filles jouent peu en club ping
eh bien j'ai appelé un des meilleurs
joueurs de france benjamins cerisier
multi-champion de paris champion de
france par équipe et en plus il joue
avec une raquette en bois
i know thy donc ça je peux vous dire que
c'est fort regarder de quoi il est
capable
si je bats ce joueur en deux points au
mini ping pong il y aura pizza pour tout
public
si je perds je mangerai moi même les
pizzas non tout ce week-end et je me
feel murray en train de manger que des
pizzas d'accord les chéris qu'on regarde
mes adversaires et qu'on appelle manable
regarder l'adversaire
[Applaudissements]
nadal conakry
on va
on est très très très très mal madame
merci d'être là nuit et un amour ça fait
cinq heures conte en direct tient les
chéris alors attention ou pizza pour
tout le monde beaucoup d'appartements ou
bien je mangerai toutes les pizzas c'est
pas la grande table non c'est pas la
grinta sa société la petite on y va tout
de suite ça ne fait pas les wav
attention on combien 3.3.3 points
gagnent allez c'est bon il faut qu'ils
gagnent il faut que publiquement
sinon c'est toi qui mange tout l'épisode
ouais je suis pas sûr qu'on va faire
trois points c'est vrai
voilà ça fait cinq heures de direct ya
quand même des gens qui ont des choses à
faire demain
moi j'ai l'épisode toi on va faire deux
points gagnants
ce que la 3 3 je pense qu'on est là
jusqu'à 4 heures du matin et vous jouez
pendant cinq heures aimer accélérée là
c'est quoi ces points n'ont cessé pour
les risques
[Rires]
you must ici quoi ils sont nos centres a
renchéri céline à balard éclater le vous
faire vérifier leur habit bleu charge en
france à la courbe
et chez les jeunes prendre une décision
ouais on fera un point gagnant un point
gagnant c'est clair les babas bonduelle
a peur d'aller cyril hanouna clair pour
le bras voilà
désolé alors j'ai ouais mais il n'a pas
servi
il a pas servi chez moi j'ai entendu une
fois que non alors il a donné un point
gagnant 1 point chacun seraient allés
chacun sert à savoir est ce que tu veux
bien servir ouais ouais enfin problème à
l'essai par le public à ce que voulaient
les pizzas allez on y va aller c'est lui
qui sert à les gens trouvent ceinture va
fermer sa gueule bien là qu'on voit que
c'est réellement niveau je ne prends pas
de risques sur ces mots là c'est beau
non mais c'est vrai mais quand sortent
comme ça on dirait ségolène c'est vrai
il a la main du capitaine comblé de
profits hologram
voilà j'attends de voir le corps du peu
de respect s'il veut ou pas de leurs
adversaires
on essaie de le déconcentrer les we were
on essaye on fait tout pour mais un
affect razer c'est respecter cet
adversaire en danger
oubliez jamais ça non pas bientôt une
calvitie ou pas vas-y ça continue en
train de faiblir mais celui de rien du
tout
damian lampe est rien sans wayne doit
que désormais les bras ballants après
minuit c'est plus cher ils sont d'abord
jours cachés tombe doublement quand on
sait
[Applaudissements]
ouais moi se défend bien
hall où les cadors ils ont pu de bras
oui bon ça joue les maîtres chanteurs
est ce que c'est bon sinon on peut aussi
on veut filmer la langue de cyril gilles
blais felice rival chatouiller je suis
pas fait un truc sympa
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
car des points ces champions de rien
attention et la rentrée la cravate là
c'était à la fois c'est selon the
guardian est encore encore pas gagné là
non pas de touche ou de services écoutez
panama a gagné bravo à lui c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
les séries les séries tonnes le père
sejalon manger des pizzas mais je veux
construire également des pizzas pour
tout le monde c'est un pizza avec h1h1
eu un très petit bonhomme rosa merci à
un pizza pour tout public
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avancé
in french cancan convient et danses
acrobatiques hamas que la pagode le
faire pour trouver la douleur en version
d'echery d'abord est avec nous voilà on
voulait vous détendre cette semaine
cancervous awards et tous et n'oubliez
pas la télé c'est que la télé on se
retrouve lundi
on vous l on sait que de l'amour et
merci d'être là avec vous à chaque fois
c'est un bonheur de l'avoir entre sans
merci à tous ces défis
[Applaudissements]
fabuleux pour les équipes pour faire
tous vertueux bon julia lalonde qui me
regarde mon chéri en cadeau elle est
finie
le chef
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]